opposition in history to be absolutely
petrified of calling a general election
and when they finally capitulated and
agreed to submit to the verdict of the
people we sent the great blue tory
ferret so far up their left trouser leg
they couldn't move we won the biggest
conservative victory since 1987. the
biggest share of the vote
since 1979 we won seats they never
dreamed of losing and we from wrexham to
workington from bishop auckland to
barrow we turned red car blue car mr
speaker we saw 54 seats go straight from
labor to tory and we won by 80 seats mr
speaker and then we worked flat out to
repay that trust with iron determination
we saw off brenda hale and we got brexit
done and though the rejoiners the
rejoiners and the revengers were left
plotting and planning and biding their
time and i will have more to say about
the events of the last few weeks and
months in due course
we delivered on every single one of our
promises no i'm not mr speaker let me
make some progress we took back control
of our money
we took back control of our borders
and we installed a points based system
for immigration
we took back control
of our laws
we on this side of the house took back
the sovereign right of the british
people to determine their own laws and
their own future
in parliament and for that i say to
colleagues on this side of the house
your place in history is secure and i
say to the honourable generation and
gentlemen it will never be forgotten
but 48 times he tried to overturn the
will of the people
48 times he tried to strike down the
biggest expression of popular will it
will be remembered in the history of
this country and be in no doubt if he
were ever to come to power mr speaker
with his hopeless coalition of liberal
democrats and scottish nationalists he
would try to do so again at the drop of
a hat
and it was only a month
or so later
that the government was forced to show
its resolve again
when we began to lose lives thousands of
lives in the worst pandemic for a
century
a pandemic that was global
whose origins we did not fully fully
understand
but
nothing to do with the british people
and if anything the result of distant
misbehavior involving bats or pangolins
and whose spread
was appallingly difficult to manage
and this government never gave up
through wave after wave and thanks to
the courage and the indomitable
resilience of the british people
we protected our nhs
we saved thousands of lives
and we were finally rescued by the
genius
of british scientists
and by a vaccine that was licensed
faster than any vaccine in the world and
a rollout that was faster than any
comparable country
and faster of course we would have
achieved if we'd listen to the leader of
the opposition mr speaker
so fast that the eu commission actually
tried to expropriate five million doses
of astra uh to try to slow us down
it can be tough
and yes shame is right and still they
failed
and insofar as the opposition
came up with any ideas at all
they would quaveringly call for more
lockdowns where we trusted to british
science and to the vaccine roll out
they vacillated we vaccinated and we
vaccinated so fast we came out of
lockdown quicker than any other european
country
and when i look at that achievement mr
speaker i tell you i have confidence in
this government and in what it can do
and as a direct result of the actions of
the government we had the fastest growth
in the g7 last year and that is why we
are able now to help people across the
country with the latest challenge the
global inflation in energy prices
triggered partly by postcoded blockages
but made far worse by putin's vile war
in ukraine
and it's because we have sensibly
managed the economy that we have the
fiscal firepower to give the most
vulnerable households
eight million of them 1200 pounds 400
pounds to help every household with the
cost of energy and we can do that
because our economic fundamentals are
strong with british companies hiring
talent up and down the country
yes with unemployment at or near a
50-year low with 60
620 000 more people in payroll
employment than there were before the
pandemic began
and youth employ youth unemployment at
or near a 45 year low and with people
coming off benefits and getting into
work 500 000 of them just in the six
months to june
and that is the fundamental difference
between government this government and
the opposition
we believe that the best answer to
poverty
is
not benefits that's what they think
we think we think the best answer is the
security
and happiness
and dignity that goes with the job
and i'm proud
i am proud of what we have done
throughout the last three years to
champion working people
lifting the living wage
cutting tax for those on universal
credit and just in the last couple of
weeks the biggest tax cut in 10 years
for the vast majority of people on lower
incomes who pay national insurance
contributions and that's why i'll give
you a fact mr speaker
that's why today under this government
the poorer households in this country
get more of their income from their
earnings
and under labor they got more of their
income from benefits that's the reality
of everything then us there has never
been a labor government that left office
with unemployment lower than when it
came in and that mr speaker is why i
have confidence in her majesty's
government in spite of
the pandemic we did not for a moment i
will give way to my older brother
i'm grateful to my right honourable
friend for giving way and i personally
think that our party is making the same
mistake that the labour party made when
they knifed tony blair but may i say to
my honorable friend is he aware
that the excess death rates in europe
show that thanks to his early
intervention with the vaccine
fewer people died in the united kingdom
than the majority of other european
countries and thanks to my right
honourable friends intervention
kiev is still a part of ukraine and not
a part of russia
well i i thank him very much and i think
look i think he's absolutely right in
what he says about the record of the nhs
the record of this country in in beating
back covert and what a pity it was that
the right honourable general officer the
leader of the opposition came so many
times uh to this place and said that we
had the worst record in europe he's
never taken it back mr speaker perhaps
he'll do so in the course of the debate
uh to come in spite of that in spite of
that pandemic in a moment it's in a
moment
we did not for a moment lose our focus
on those huge manifesto commitments that
we made in 2019
beginning with making our streets safer
and with the help of now 13
576 more police and we will hit we will
hit 20 000 by 2024
we have rounded up those county lines
drugs gangs
fifteen hundred of them so far and we
all could wait we've taken thousands of
knives off the streets of of of our
country and using stop and search mr
speaker
using stop and search and i know that
people on labor benches oppose stop and
search but i think it is the kindest and
most loving thing you can do when
someone is going equipped with a bladed
weapon to take that knife off him mr
speaker
and it was by tough policing giving the
police the powers that they deserve and
putting him out on the street we've
helped to get neighborhood crime down by
31
and as we promised we've invested
massively in our amazing nhs we got the
nurses into the hospitals i think
another ten thousand this year on last
year on track to recruit fifty thousand
we have record numbers of people working
now in our nhs mr speaker tackling the
coveted
and at the same time we're getting on
with our long-term program of
improvement of our national health
service and uh they constantly say that
we're not going to build uh 14 new
hospitals mr speaker well i can tell him
that we are and and they will be done by
2030 and he will if he's still around in
2024 he will see measurable improvement
and i'll tell you something else mr
speaker 75 years after the foundation of
the nhs we have been the first
government to haven't have the nerve
and a plan
to fix the gulf between the nhs and
social care
ending the cruel lottery that brings
destitution on families with a member
suffering from dementia governments have
promised it for decades we did it mr
speaker we're raising the funding to do
which they opposed and of course we've
been investing massively in our schools
and young people introducing hundreds of
thousands of kids to tutoring the kind
of tutoring uh kids who have potential
kids are in danger of being left behind
the kind of tutoring there is that is
currently only available to those whose
parents can pay for it
and in making i'm going to give away i'm
going to give way to the uh to my former
opponent
the owner of the right old memphis into
north i'm grateful to the prime minister
for taking a break from his fantasy tour
of this country
[Applause]
could he
could he take one moment to explain
why
14 million people in this country are
living in poverty why there are more
food banks than there are branches of
mcdonald's
why there is a mental health crisis why
big pharma have made so much out of
owning the patents of the vaccines why
his government is presiding over the
enriching of the richest the
impoverishment of the poorest and the
greatest job in security in industry
after industry he has created poverty
inequality and insecurity that
[Music]
uh to be debating again with the right
honourable gentleman uh and and and
since i since our last encounters uh i
can tell him i am proud that we've
actually got unemployment down uh to at
all no uh record lows i know i know that
he'd rather have people uh on benefits
but i don't think that's the way forward
mr speaker and he talks about 14 million
uh people uh let let me tell him 40
million people uh voted 14 million
people voted uh for this conservative
government uh and and this conservative
government is undefeated at the polls
and that
and never let that be forgotten of
course at the same time just a moment
we've been we've been investing
we've been investing massively in in
schools as i say and it's it's by making
uh our streets and our communities safer
by making our population healthier by uh
ensuring that our kids are literate and
numerate at the age of 11 and our goal
is to get up to 90 percent uh by 11
rather than the current 65 mr speaker
we've been driven throughout this last
three years by a very simple vision we
conservatives believe that there is
genius and talent everywhere an energy
and imagination
distributed in every corner of this
country
but we don't think that's the same for
opportunity mr speaker
and our immense program of leveling up
is driven by the simple mathematical
observation if per capita gdp
productivity were evenly distributed in
the uk as they are in our major
competitors then this would be by some
way the most prosperous economy in
europe and of course it would also be
the morally right thing to do mr speaker
and that's why we've kept going with the
most colossal infrastructure program
ever seen three new high-speed uh rail
lines uh mr speaker and by the way how
many miles of electrified line
did labor build in their 13 years of
office anybody know
virtually virtually none hundreds of
miles of road improvements we're putting
putting in massive investments in buses
in cycling and of course we gave people
and we are giving people the skills
skills skills the lifetime skills
guarantee that means the government will
support you to get an a-level equivalent
skill when you're an adult and mr
speaker we're also giving them the
technology to use those skills
throughout the country gigabit broadband
i am proud to say nice sprites through
every wayne school or virtually every
wednesday we've gone from we've gone
from seven percent to 69
coverage uh in this brief uh in this
brief three years and it's only by
putting in
only by putting in the infrastructure
only by putting in the infrastructure
she says they don't have wi-fi in the
north mr speaker and let me say
it is this government that's what she
said it is this government that is
putting on wi-fi across the whole how
little she knows how little she knows of
the very area she purports to represent
it's only by putting in the
infrastructure that you enable people to
live where they want and i'm proud that
uh that not only do we see record
numbers of of homes being built uh last
year there were 400 000 first time
buyers because unlike the party opposite
we believe in home ownership we believe
in getting people on the property ladder
they don't like it you can tell they
don't like it mr speaker and the better
the infrastructure the skills the
technology the less 400 000 first-time
buyers
the less intrusive the less intrusive
the regulation in our country the more
the investment flows in and we're seeing
huge sums coming now from the private
sector every other week there is another
billion pound unicorn not just in london
or oxford or cambridge but across the
whole country we have more tech
investment than france and germany and
israel combined and now in the first
quarter this year in attracting tech
venture capital we've actually overtaken
the chinese and mr speaker with 12.5
billion coming in
and this this government this government
will continue to make the uk the place
to come
for the industries and the businesses of
the future
this uni this year newquay
will join cape kennedy and baikonur as a
functioning spaceport i'm proud to say
and for the first time ever
under this government
a british satellite will be launched
into space
from britain
and next year the spaceport in shetland
will roar in tonight thanks to the
investments from lockheed martin and
others as local crafters
local crafters
i mean
humble crofters mr speaker
almost as humble and local as the right
honourable gentleman opposite
how withdrawn their opposition because
they can see that it means jobs and
growth for their area
and
people in this in this in this house may
not know
may not know it but this government has
made an investment in low earth orbit
satellites and it was a risk
uh hundreds of them but it has paid off
for the taxpayer and hundreds and
hundreds of them and now circling the
earth offering all sorts of
opportunities including the potential
for internet uh connections for the
people of sub-saharan africa
and
i will give way uh one last time to to
honorable about that
i'm grateful to the honourable general
it is highly unconventional to put down
a confidence motion in his own
government though i suppose he's an
unconventional person since only an
unconventional man would want the
opportunity to speak at his own funeral
so
so can i can i ask him though isn't his
essential problem despite all this
litany
that he thinks are his fantasy
achievements the bottom line is this
government this country is supposed to
operate on the good chap theory of
government but it doesn't operate when
there's a bad apple at the core
mr speaker i think look he's if he if
he's saying that he is going to
vote for confidence in this government i
will certainly welcome uh welcome his
support but i what i can tell him is
that uh i believe that the achieve the
achievements of this government over the
last three years i think have been uh
very remarkable and uh and
as for his personal criticism of me i am
proud of what we have done and i'm proud
i am proud of the way uh that i've been
able to offer leadership in difficult
times let me put it let me put it that
way
i think that that investment of the in
the lower low earth orbit satellites has
paid off and as i said that uh people in
sub-saharan africa now have the chance
to get internet connection uh it's it's
a massive massive success for for global
britain and uh people around the world
can now see the renewed ambition of this
country the record 22 billion pounds
we're investing to become a science
superpower again the new advanced
research and innovation agency and of
course at the same time
the scientific solutions that we are
providing are helping to solve the
fundamental problems facing humanity and
on this sweltering day
on this sweltering day let me just
remind the house
there are very few governments in the
world that could have organized a cop 26
summit
so far-reaching in its impacts and i i i
thank my uh my right honorable friend
and colleague the member for reading for
what he did uh committing 90 of the
world to net zero uh by 2050
moving the world beyond the use of coal
moving from fossil fuel cars to to evs
planting billions of trees around the
world and launching the clean green
initiative as we did at carbus bay
by which g7 governments will now
leverage the trillions of the private
sector to help the developing world to
use the clean green technologies that
offer
economic as well as environmental
salvation and i think people around the
world can see more clearly than ever
before
that
uh
we have in this country and i think in
this house a renewed willingness
as global britain
to stand up for freedom and democracy
and you could have no better proof of
that than our campaign to help the
ukrainians
and if it is if it is
if it is true
that i'm more popular on the streets of
kiev right now than i am in kensington
if
that is because of the of the foresight
and boldness of this government in
becoming the first european country to
send them weapons
a decision that was made possible by the
biggest investment in defense since the
cold war and
now i think that conflict will continue
to be very hard
and i think our thoughts and prayers
must continue to be with the people of
ukraine
i do believe
that they must win and that they will
win
and
though there may be of course a massive
strategic
importance in the face of putin's
adventurism and aggression
when the people of ukraine
have won
it will also be a victory
of right over wrong and of good over
evil
and i think this government saw that
clearly and saw it whole and saw it
faster than many other parts of the
world and that mr speaker is why i have
confidence in this government by the way
i have absolutely zero confidence in the
opposition
i don't think
eight of eight of them voted tara
singers and you mercedes everybody will
say this right until the next eight of
them including the shadow foreign
secretary voted to discard this
country's independent nuclear weapon mr
speaker i don't believe they would have
done the same thing in standing up to
putin in a month of sundays mr speaker
last week i last week i went up in one
of our
148 typhoon
fighters and i i flew out over the north
sea mr speaker i flew out over
dogaland
the drowned prairies that are now being
harvested again with tens of gigawatts
of clean green energy
we will have 50 gigawatts of offshore
wind by 2050.
and thanks to this government's activism
i'm proud to say that offshore wind is
now cheaper than onshore wind yeah yeah
and you know i looked down at that
ghostly uh white forest of a windmills
in the sea uh financed by the way with
ever-growing sums from international
investors and i thought this is how we
are going to fix our energy problems
this is how europe should be ending its
dependence on putin's gas and i am proud
of the way we have responded to the
challenge a nuclear reactor every year
mr speaker
rather than one every uh 10 years or
none at all as was the ridiculous policy
the catastrophic policy of the last
labour government
and then
and then the
and then the on and then the
and then the wing commander
the wing commander interrupted me i i'm
i'm and and he
for a glorious period i was at the
controls of the i i i of the typhoon and
i did a loop the loop and the nailer on
roll and a barrel roll and then
i'm coming to the point mr speaker
i handed back the controls
and in a few weeks time that is exactly
what i will do with this great party of
ours and after three dynamic and
exhilarating years
in the cockpit
we will find a new leader
and we will coalesce in loyalty around
him or her
[Applause]
[Music]
and the vast twin engines twin rolls
royce engines of our touring message our
conservative values and race will roar
on listening
strong
strong public services
strong public services on the left
and a dynamic free market enterprise
economy on the right
each boosting the other and developing
trillions of pounds of thrust
and the reason we keep winning
is that we are the only party that
understands the need for both and
whatever happens in this contest we will
continue to fight for the lowest
possible taxes and the lightest possible
regulation and their problem mr speaker
is that they would try to fly on one
engine
endlessly cow towing to the union barons
endlessly inflicting more tax and more
spending endlessly giving in to the
temptation to regulate us back into the
orbit of the european union and flying
around in circles and some people will
say as i as i leave office
that this is the end of
yep they will they will say this is the
end of brexit
they will oh yes
listen to deathly hard
deathly hush
and the leader of the opposition and the
deep state will prevail in its plot to
haul us back into alignment with the eu
as a prelude to our eventual return
and we on this side of the house will
prove them wrong won't we
[Applause]
[Music]
and
and some people will say
that this is the end of our support some
people say
that this is the end of our support for
ukraine
i'm told
that is exactly the
the analysis the champansky corks of
allegedly been popping in the
in the kremlin
just as i just as the
the islington lefties are toasting each
other with their favorite kia waiau
mr speaker
well i have no doubt that whoever takes
over
whoever takes over in a few weeks time
will make sure that we keep together the
global coalition in support of our
ukrainian friends
and some people will say that my
departure
i think it was the leader of the
opposition himself who said it
the leader of
my departure means the eventual victory
of the labour party
and i believe this side of the house
will prove him totally wrong
and in due course we will walk the
honourable member for hoban and some
pancras into that capsule in yuki that i
have talked about earlier and sent him
into orbit where he belongs and mr
speaker i i tell my right my right or my
friend uh the member for the scots
nationalist that it is time that he
takes his protein pill and puts his
helmet on uh mr speaker because it won't
be long i hear before his own party is
taking him to sheffield uh to shetland i
should say and propelling him to the
heavens
mr speaker this
government
has fought
some of the hardest yards
in modern political history
we've had to take
some of the bleakest decisions since the
war
and
i believe that we got
the big calls right
and at the end of
and at the end of three years this
country is visibly using its newfound
independence to turbo charge its natural
our natural advantages
as the best place in the world not just
to live and and to invest but to bring
up a family and with a new
and incontrovertible spirit of global
leadership
i believe that we can look to the future
with a rock solid confidence
not just in what this government has
done
but it what it will do and will continue
to do
and i commend this motion to the house
the question is
[Music]
[Applause]
the question is that this is confidence
in her majesty's government
we will wait and see look who we are i
know called the leader of the opposition
kirsten
[Applause]
mr speaker the delusion is never-ending
exactly
what a relief
what a relief for the country that they
finally got around to sacking him
[Applause]
and in many ways the chaos of the last
fortnight is familiar
the third tory leadership contest in six
years
the latest bumper summer for graphic
designers and brand managers
the latest parade of pretenders
promising unfunded tax cuts
latest set of minister of jobs handed
out on a wink and a shake in return for
a nomination
and tv debates so embarrassing that even
the contestants are pulling out
every other year they switch out a
failed prime minister
it's like a one secure premier league
side burning through managers as they
slide inevitably towards relegation
but mr speaker
the end of the season can't come soon
enough
but
besides the deja vu
things are different this time
david cameron left office
david cameron left office because he
lost a referendum
the right honourable member from
maidenhead left office because her party
could not agree on how to leave the eu
there were serious policy and political
disagreements
and on how to grow the economy how to
run our public services the labour party
had our own profound disagreements with
both former prime ministers
but
but no one seriously disputed that they
were fit for office
that they could be trusted to carry out
their own i suggest some of those on the
opposite side re-read their resignation
letters
[Applause]
no one
no one seriously disputed that they were
fit for office
that they could be trusted to carry out
their responsibilities
that the information they gave their
ministers was true to the best of their
knowledge
and the policies they proposed were the
ones that they believed were best for
the country
so no one objected to them staying on
whilst the successor was found
not at the moment
now there clearly are policy
disagreements between the prime minister
and his party
i know he spent the weekend throwing
another party obviously a very good
party from the last 20 minutes
but it he can i
can i suggest
can i suggest to use this catch-up tv
to see what they've been saying in the
leadership debates
the foreign secretary says the prime
minister's economic policy
is not going to drive economic growth
she's left now
the
member for portsmouth north said they've
left public services in a state of
disrepair
and the member for safran walden says
junior ministers raised concerns about
fraud that were ignored and cost the
taxpayer 17 billion pounds
that's on that side this is what they're
saying prime minister in the leadership
debates
so the people behind him are not happy
with his record whatever they say in
june now
but unlike his predecessors
this prime minister has not been forced
out over policy disagreements
and despite the delusions he's fostered
in his bunker he's not been felled by
the stampede of an eccentric herd
instead
he's been forced out
in disgrace
[Music]
judged
judged by his colleagues and peers to be
unworthy of his position
and unfit for his office
he promoted someone he knew to be a
sexual predator
might be an idea to listen
and then denied all knowledge when that
inevitably went wrong
he lied to his ministers about what he
knew
and allowed them to repeat those lies to
the country
it's the same pattern of behavior that
we saw when he and his mates parted
through lockdown
denied it for months
and forced his ministers to repeat those
lies until he was found out
he can't change
even last week he was tearing up the
rules by insisting that an opposition
motion of no confidence could not be
heard
he promoted an ally to the minister or
payroll as she literally gave the public
the middle finger
and he appointed a chancellor with
questions to answer about tax avoidance
and his personal finances
they all know
they
[Music]
[Applause]
say
[Applause]
they all know
[Music]
mr speaker the chair has been very clear
at times about being conscious of
language now from my understanding the
right remember to strap upon having to
whom i think the right of all know the
gentleman's appearing to
deny that accusation perhaps you could
guide the right of winning gentleman
[Applause]
i want everybody to think carefully
about what they see in this chamber and
the effects it has on people and it does
concern but also it's better now the
clerks myself could hear i love what's
going on so if you just turn it down so
we can't hear here's starman
thank you mr speaker
they all know it can't go on
just read their resignation letters
the member for southwest wiltshire
went after saying this is the last straw
in the rolling chaos
the member for cheltenham had enough of
defending the indefensible
and the member for bolsover simply said
the prime minister was an apologist for
someone who has committed sexual assault
when the right honourable member for
richmond resigned
he accused the prime minister of not
conducting government properly
competently
or seriously
i presume he was talking about the
appalling joint economic legacy
the highest inflation and the lowest
growth in the g7
leaving us with the highest tax burden
since rationing and diminished public
services
that's the record
the rhetoric doesn't match it
he suggested the prime minister is not
prepared to work hard
or take difficult decisions
and implied that the prime minister
cannot tell the public the truth
they all read the letter they know what
he said
but this week
but this week
this week the right honourable member
for richmond is trying to convince us to
ignore all that apparently he's changed
his mind asked a straight question
he won't tell his party that the prime
minister is dishonest
and now he's saying the prime minister
is actually a remarkable man with a good
heart
pathetic
there can be no one worse place to
rebuild the economy than the man who
broke it
there can be no one worse place to
restore trust than the man who propped
up this totally untrustworthy prime
minister i'll make some progress and i
will
well it's instead instead of rewriting
history members opposite need to face up
to what they've done
what they've put this country through
despite knowing exactly who he is
despite knowing that he always puts
himself before anyone else
despite knowing that he'd been fired
from job after job for lying
they elected him to lead their party
and he behaved exactly as everyone
feared when he got into her downing
street
he lurched from one scandal to the next
he demeaned his office
and he started to drag everyone and
everything down with him
so belatedly they found him unfit for
office
too untrustworthy for government
honourable gentleman
the right honourable gentleman sounds
like he's describing his own actions but
for year after year he sat in the he sat
there while the labour party were found
guilty of breaching the law by the echr
on the anti-semitism of the honourable
member of his england north why didn't
he have the courage to stand up at the
time and stand up for what's right
apologies peter
i wonder if he actually realizes why
we're having this debate
it's because
it's because it's because so many
you've lost me
they sold and quite rightly asked the
question and also like yourself would
like to hear the answers
let's move on we're having this debate
because dozens of front benchers
resigned their posts
because they wouldn't serve this prime
minister
they're sucking him because he's
untrustworthy that's why we're having
this debate normally in a debate like
this the prime minister is asking for a
vote of confidence so we can carry on
this one's already
i'm very bothered about where this is
going the use of language needs to be
brought into a more temperament manner
and whatever light says we need to calm
it down you know and let's see how we
can try and progress in a more orderly
but more temperament in what we're
saying
so mr speaker
why are they leaving him
with his hands on the levers of power
for eight weeks
eight weeks
where the british public must trust the
word of a prime minister who's been
sacked because he can't be trusted
eight weeks
where britain will be represented abroad
by someone who's lost all respect at
home
eight weeks of a caretaker government
led by an utterly careless prime
minister
and
anyone who thinks that doesn't matter
that this is just a quiet summer months
where everyone goes to the beach is in
denial about the severity of the
challenges our country faces
the war in eastern ukraine drags off
the north stream pipeline has been shut
down
flights are being cancelled left right
and center britain is facing an
unprecedented heatwave
as our climate changes
in our very eyes
these are serious
mr speaker they don't think that these
are challenges
[Music]
these are serious issues that will
require serious leadership hard
decisions will have to be made this is
not
the summer for downing street to be
occupied by a vengeful squatter mired in
scandal
mr speaker
mr speaker every day
every day they leave him there
every hustings they refuse to distance
himself from his appalling behavior
and every vote they cast today to prop
him up is a dereliction
[Music]
[Applause]
it's a reminder it's a reminder mr
speaker that the prime minister has only
been able to do what he's done
because he's enabled by a corrupted
conservative party every step every
scandal and every party along the way
sadly that's complete nonsense but you
can see why they fear the electorate
after 12 years of failed tory government
britain is stuck
stuck with a low growth economy
stuck at home unable to get a passport
or a flight
stuck on the phone trying to get a gp
appointment
our taxes are going up food and energy
bills are out of control
and the public services we rely on have
simply stopped working
and every tory standing to
lead their party has given up on trying
to defend
prime minister
they've they have no confidence in you
that's why you're going
really are struggling to hear
now i want to be able to hear then we
can make better judgment calls both the
clarkson myself are struggling and all i
would say is please can we calm it down
and think about what we see here
thank you mr speaker
britain deserves a fresh start with
labour
free from those
who got us stuck in the first place
free from the chaotic tory party
free from those that propped up this
prime minister for months and months
and here's the difference under my
leadership the labour party has changed
and we're ready to do the same for the
country too to get our economy growing
to revitalize our public services and
after this prime minister has damaged
everything around him to clean up
politics this house should make a start
by voting no confidence in this prime
minister this evening
father of the house to peter bottomley
mr speaker
in june
2016
there was a vote of no confidence
in the then leader of the labour party
i don't know whether the president leave
the labor party voted yes or voted no
did he vote confidence in his
predecessor or devote no confidence in
his predecessor
if he can remember
in 2019
his predecessor moved a motion of no
confidence in the government
saying the issue should be put to the
people
it was put to the people there was a
general election in 2019
and the present government came in with
a majority of 80.
[Applause]
and i have it on reasonable authority
that the deputy leader of the labor
party has said today
that boris was in effect the magic
which helped
[Music]
i'm glad she's confirmed that
the issue before the house now
is whether people would have any more
confidence
in the labor party becoming a government
and the answer is no
if we can return mr speaker
to that no competence vote in june 2016
when the leader of the labor party lost
by 172 to 40
and the 14 may have included the
honourable gentleman leave the
opposition
at that moment twenty of the shadow
cabinets had walked out
the right woman gentlemen for hobart and
some pancreas walked in
[Applause]
i think the interesting question
is whether the way he's spoken today
is actually uh a leadership bid he's
trying to take over the labour party
properly rather than just in name
and whether he can
whether
and whether he can lead
what he describes himself as red and
green
if you put red and green together you
get a rather unpleasant kind of brown
or whether he's going to accept
that the labour party
has not yet been trusted by the british
people
i would say to this house
that by voting against no confidence in
fact voting confidence in the government
by saying on balance as the british
people did in 2019
they prefer us to be in government and
not them
that's not to say the government's got
everything right
i could if i were taking part in the
thursday sir david amos debate list the
things where i want government to make
changes i want to drop the privatization
of channel four there's no point in it
i'd like them to reconsider the question
of whether the holocaust memorial should
be in victoria tower gardens and there
are a number of other issues i could
take up but this is not that issue the
issue today do we want to change the
party of government
and the answer is no
i rest my case there
we now come to the leader of the snp in
blackfoot
thank you uh mr speaker i see the prime
minister is
leaving the chamber in this particular
case prime minister leave means leave
[Music]
we all know that the government has
spent the last week trying to delay
rewards and ultimately avoid this debate
but
as is the way these days
the herd moved
so today
we finally have a chance to cast our
verdict on a failed prime minister
and a conservative party that is
collapsing before our very eyes
and i know that the government wants to
use this debate as some kind of
dignified although i haven't seen any
dignity from the prime minister this
afternoon obituary for the political
legacy of the leader that they buried
last week
but if the government are determined to
debate the legacy of the prime minister
then let's allow ourselves the
opportunity to be that one thing that he
singularly failed to be
let's be very very honest
let's reflect on a man
who should never have been put in office
in the first place
a man
that simply shouldn't be here
for a minute longer because he
demonstrated
no dignity in office in the highest
office in the land and he's shown
no dignity today
and so every single member of this house
needs to ask themselves a very simple
question
why on earth
does the prime minister deserve the
dignity of a long goodbye and a seven
week chance to rewrite his own legacy
and mr speaker
apparently
the one and only reason being offered up
by tory mps to justify keeping him in
place is because we're told that that is
the precedent that is the way that it
works down here it's the westminster way
but those citing any kind of precedent
have clearly forgotten the exact reason
that we've been brought to this point
the behavior of this prime minister
has no precedence
i'm
relieved that we can hear the speech
with the right honourable gentleman now
and we have no longer the prime minister
bawling at speakers as he
then leaves the chamber
but what do you agree would you agree
that what we want over this change is
dignity
the hell dignity in the house dignity in
the country and we didn't see it from
the prime minister in his behavior on
that trump bench today order order
i think i made that decision and i don't
need any recommendations i think the
behavior from both sides hasn't been
exceptional today
come on
thank you mr speaker i have to say i i
agree with
my my honourable friend that it's
important that these are these are
matters that are of interest to the
public and we need to treat each other
with a degree of respect and dignity and
let's come back to the prime minister
because he broke his own laws in office
he broke international law and of course
the thing that ultimately brought him
down
the fact that he could never ever be
trusted with the truth that is the
record
and that is now the prime minister's
legacy
he shouldn't be allowed
any room to rewrite that record in that
legacy even for seven weeks
because
mr speaker
it hasn't escaped anyone's notice that
this prime minister has lived his life
thinking that the world owes him a
living and he hasn't had the grace to
stay today
to hear the opening speeches in this
debate that tells you everything that
you need to know mr speaker
how happy
i thank my right honourable friend
and he's making an excellent speech
does he agree with me that the prime
minister today spoke for 30 minutes
and not once in what could be his last
speech did he make reference to the
real facts that because of political
decisions he made
children are living in poverty working
families are using food banks and the
devastation he has caused our
communities does he agree he should have
at least had the dignity in his last
speech to apologize to the children in
our country
i i agree with
my honorable friend and let me commend
him for the passion that he brings to
this topic because the fact that so many
people are struggling in this country
and so many people are going to be
struggling over the cost of living
crisis is something that should concern
all of us one more time yeah
i do thank the right honourable member
for giving way
we talk about food banks we talk about
poverty it is the fact that many
households something that promises
referred to as some of the poorest in
the land many households in my
constituency have no alternative but to
use fuel oil they're off grid
and when i asked the minister of state
for
energy in march would there be a cap
placed on it he said no because there
had been some survey in 2011. today is a
very hot day but winter is coming and it
will be cold
so can i suggest that i don't remember
that this is a mark of a civilized a
caring government that these people
should be helped
and that a price cap should be put on
the cost of fuel oil domestic heating
oil
i agree with uh
my honorable friend we both represent
highland constituencies beautiful
constituencies
but constituencies for the rain falls on
a regular basis and the wind howls
through the
windows through the walls of these
houses
and mr speaker yes indeed
there ought to be equity and fairness
for everyone regardless of where they
live
and of course we're talking about the
heat wave that people are suffering from
in many parts of the united kingdom
today but actually when i looked at the
weather in my own constituency in the
isle of skye this morning the
temperature was 14 degrees
people in parts of scotland will still
have their heating load and the fact
that people are being penalized and that
people are not being looked after the
way that they should be for the very
simple reason that they have to rely on
off-grid heating oils
um i'm sure he appreciates that the
reason that the chancellor gave the
assistance to people on their
electricity bills not their gas bills is
because people may use fuel oil or other
types of fuel but almost everyone in the
country is on the electricity grid
well my goodness my goodness my goodness
mr speaker and i'm very angry i have
respect for the honorable gentleman he
knows that
but they're for all to see
they're for all to see
is the lack of compassion
the decency the humanity and the
recognition that people in highland
constituencies are not getting the
benefits that other people get that's
what happens with this conservative
government let's come back to the
prime minister and that sense of
entitlement
that he deserved to be prime minister
that he deserved to be above the rules
that he deserves the dignity of staying
in office over the summer
but this place
and the public
or the prime minister nothing
only this weekend
he again showed why he is unfit for
office
skipping cobra meetings
to do his favorite thing
attending yet another party
another party
you know the one thing you would have
thought that he might learn
when he was
caught breaking his own laws when he's
fined by the metropolitan police the
only prime minister in history
to be fined in office
and he turns his back on his obligations
at a time of uh an emergency overheating
over the effect of global warming
and his attending parties that tells you
everything
mr speaker that we need to know about
the priorities of this prime minister
people have suffered enough
under this most careless casual and
reckless inhabitant ever to have been
entreated with the office of prime
minister he doesn't deserve another day
never mind another seven weeks
mr speaker as well as casting verdict on
the prime minister today it is also a
chance to hold to account those who
propped up
his government
for so long
because
with every new candidate and every new
campaign video for the tory leadership
we're literally being bombarded with
talks of fresh starts
or hitting the reset button
i hate to break it to them but it isn't
lost at any of us that most of the talk
is coming from the very same people who
backed as prime minister from day one
and sat around the cabinet table until
the very end try as they might they
can't hide the uncomfortable truth that
they want to solve to magically forget
that their party has been in power for
12 deeply damaging years fresh starts
new starts or clean starts simply don't
exist after 12 years of the chaos that
now defines their time in charge
they definitely don't exist when they've
already failed to get rid of the prime
minister that they put in power the herd
might have moved last week
but they're very quickly falling back in
line and reverted to tory type just as
we've seen this afternoon the tories
have stayed with this prime minister
until the bitterest of ends and today
proves that they're staying with him
still
their failure
to get rid of the prime ministers means
that we now finally need to get rid of
the lot of them because today proves
another thing the only fresh start we
need the only fresh start that will work
is a general election
an election that will offer the people
of scotland the chance and the choice
of an independent future
and on these benches
we relish that campaign
and the choice that is coming
the need to put an end to this tory
government is undermined underlined by
the terrifying spectacle of the
leadership race that is underway
throughout this building because
no sooner had the race begun and it
became very clear that it wasn't just a
race to getting to downing street it was
a race to the toxic right
the policy proposals so far have
amounted to tax cuts for the rich at the
very same time that millions of families
are struggling to put food on the table
watering down
our climate targets
when we can literally feel
that temperatures particularly in this
place are soaring
and doubling down on the hostile
environment when the rwanda policy has
already gone beyond the point of
morality
the new tory vision of these candidates
is every bit as disturbing as the old
one
and while they're all tearing lumps out
of each other in this contest they're
ignoring the very thing that they're
responsible for
the tory cost of living crisis is
ripping through every household and
these islands
the contents contest has also exposed
that they're completely out of
credibility never again
can the opposite benches claim economic
literacy
because
during this leadership campaign the tory
candidates haven't just discovered one
magic money tree they've apparently
found the magic money forest
the billions in tax breaks for the rich
they are bidding over always always
come at the price for the poor
and one of the most
telling insights of the contest
came from the current chancellor
whose policies to cut 20
for all public spending so that's 20
cuts to the nhs to welfare and to our
scottish parliament the tories imposed
one decade of devastating austerity and
now it seems
the new tory vision
is gearing up to inflict another
if there ever was a reason to vote no
confidence today
surely that is it
and of course mr speaker
on these benches we are now well used to
our country's constitutional future
being discussed and dictated to by tory
politicians and governments who scotland
hasn't voted for and or had any
confidence in since
1955
the last number of weeks
have been no different
and it turns out
democracy denial was not just an
attitude of the prime minister
it's now official tory policy the idea
of voluntary union of nations has
clearly been dead and buried long ago
according to the tory party because
every single candidate for the tory
leadership has fallen over themselves to
tell us just how they're going to deny
scottish democracy
and we know why
they have long since run out of ideas
and run out of road in defending the
union so now they're running scared of
democracy
and i'm sorry to say
i'm genuinely sorry to say
that the labour party has joined in that
too
in the space of the last week
the leader of the labour party told us
he was reeling out two things
the first was ruling out an independence
referendum
that let's not forget
that the scottish people have voted for
the second
the second mr speaker
was ruling out a return to the european
single market
and freedom of movement
he didn't rule it out for now
he's ruled it out forever
so
not only will this place
and these parties try to deny our right
to do a democratic vote in our future
but they will forever deny our return to
the european union
if there were ever two motivating
arguments to secure our independence
surely those are it
it really is the better together
strategy they're in worse trouble than i
even thought because mr speaker
the crucial point that those reunited
better together parties need to fully
understand is this
not only
does scotland have no confidence in this
tory government we have no confidence in
westminster control of our country
the parties here might not like it
they might try to deny it
but that's democracy
but that's democracy
and then and then are the breaks we want
a different future a future where we get
governments we vote for when our
democratically elected parliament cannot
be overridden and undermined and where
we have a secure foundation on which to
build the economic and social future
that we want
a new scotland
at the heart of the european union
that is the future we can have
confidence
we have lost
control in this place
we've lost confidence in westminster
[Music]
lots of members want to speak in this
debate to try and accommodate it can we
start off by saying let's say for four
minutes remedy
the order paper
which is in front of us
is a motion about no confidence in her
majesty's government
and when we face this cost of living
crisis and war in europe and all the
other challenges
i was rather hoping when i arrived here
we might have a serious debate
about how we can deal with these issues
instead i have heard
a speech from the leader of the
opposition which in terms of by
cooperation and insult and sheer
nastiness
[Applause]
i don't think i've ever heard anything
like it before certainly in terms of a
prime minister who will be leaving
office in a very few weeks
where is any sense of kindness or
magnanimity
why do we need to
throw these insults around
and claim i'm i'm just going to proceed
if i may and claim that this is the
worst sort of
mass murder and criminal in political
history it's complete it's complete
rubbish
the fact is
that
when this prime minister took power
parliament
parliament's reputation was in tatters
virtually everybody in this chamber
had no
virtually everybody in this chamber had
voted to have a referendum
and yet large parts
many members were doing their level best
to frustrate it and if we had not had
this prime minister if we had not
delivered brexit i believe that we would
have had a meltdown in political trust
absolutely he got brexit done yeah so we
got brexit done and i agree we would
have i would personally have liked to
have done a lot more with it and we will
do given time so that's the first issue
that's why the prime minister was given
a majority of 80. the second issue is
the pandemic we've had all these insults
about against the prime minister who was
working on our behalf and nearly died in
office absolutely
absolutely and he was working flat out
and he saved it's a disgraceful attack
he was working flat out to save lives
and our record on the pandemic frankly
is second to none and again and again
the opposition was trying to force us
into more and more severe lockdowns and
this prime minister with his vaccine
rollout got us out of that mess and
thousands of people are now alive
because of this prime minister
so speaking for myself i holy regret the
departure of this prime minister and i
remain completely loyal to him to the
very end as i remain loyal to mrs
thatcher and i think we will ask
ourselves what have we done
what have we done to a man who gave us
this 80-seat majority
and the third point
is the butt for this prime minister the
first
western leader to arm ukraine kiev would
now be in the hands of the russians
absolutely we led europe we led the
world in saving this country this is the
record of this prime minister and i am
proud
as a backbencher to have given him all
the loyalty i possibly could and as i
would give loyalty to the next leader of
course there are challenges
anybody would think
that we live in a vacuum
that despite the fact that we have this
pandemic despite or had it despite the
fact that we have this war in europe
that somehow the government is to blame
for all our ills this is complete
rubbish and when the next leader of the
conservative party the next prime
minister comes into office within weeks
the labour party will be calling for
another general election
as we've already heard from the
alt-right honourable gentleman they will
say this new prime minister is unelected
elected by you know a fairly small
number of people
they never said that about the previous
prime minister because he was elected by
the people with an 80 seat majority so
the problems are not going to go away
and we all know
in reality that if the labor party had
been in power the outcomes of the
pandemic may not have been a great deal
different we don't know what happened
with ukraine we don't know what will
happen with the economy but the
conservative party as the prime minister
explained is turbocharged because we
believe in the power of the free economy
and freedom and in low taxation of
course we can't deliver it now and i say
to these uh my friends who are competing
for leadership be responsible
be responsible i know it's the popular
thing to call for tax cuts now
but we do have level
we have record levels of borrowing
you know if you have record levels of
borrowing you do not solve the problem
by borrowing more and more and when it's
said that you can put the covid expense
in a particular box and we forget it can
forget about it for 50 years that
doesn't matter debt is debt we all know
in our private life you can't say to nat
west well i've got this debt on my car
or something i want to put it on a in a
different box and i won't have to pay
for 50 years debt is debt
the conservative party
reputation is built on economic
confidence competence we have to be
careful with the economy i personally
was very unhappy about the rise in
national insurance contributions i'm not
in favor of tax rises i believe the
reputation of a conservative government
depends on low tax we want to cut tax
but i say to these leadership continued
contenders that we must be responsible
and
in conclusion i hope
[Music]
i'm only trying to give a law speech to
my party which is surely no bad thing
and to the present leader of my party
because ultimately no i better stop now
because they they've had enough of me
[Music]
ultimately the secret weapon of the tory
party is loyalty
dean margaret
[Music]
the honorable member for gainsborough is
right that these uh confidence motions
can defeat
descend into pointless political attacks
but the reality is that it's this
government and this prime minister and
what they've done in a po makes us all
oppose today's motion it's fundamental
this motion is fundamental for anybody
who wants to uphold democracy defend
integrity and restore trust it's not
just partygate madam deputy speaker
dreadful though that was
not failed attempt to defend the
indefensible behavior of owen patterson
not the abhorrent culture of tolerating
bullying and sexual harassment from
political allies these contribute to a
loss of confidence but they don't stand
alone
there's an endless list of incompetence
and waste taxpayers money being tossed
around like confetti with 16 billion
fraudulently squandered on covered
business support shameful failures in
ambulance waiting times and 6 million
citizens waiting for hospital treatment
people unable to travel because of the
crippling delays in the passport office
a stream of rail strikes and chaos at
the airports
all of that is unforgivable but it's the
creeping culture of corruption and the
determination to close down those whose
job it is to keep a check on executive
power that makes this government unfit
for office
there's a growing body of evidence of
corruption dodgy russian money funding
mps on the tory path
an explosion in illicit finance
with london grad and now the
international capital for dirty money
peerages for pals like fraudulent
lebanese jobs for mates like james
wharton to people from the prime
minister city hall days
contracts for cronies with only 0.2
million of the 17.3 billion contracts
for ppe subject to open competitions
this is not madame definitely speaker
the prime minister's money not the
conservative money it's our money
taxpayers money earned through hard work
and we expect it to be honestly and
efficiently spent
this government has no moral compass
look at their reaction when criticized
by institutions that provide a check on
their power when the courts found the
government to illegally prorogue
parliament they look to limit judicial
review when international laws prove
inconvenient they break or ignore them
parliament's role in holding government
to account has been eroded ministers
refusing to appear at select committee
primarily interfering parliamentary
elections legislation being rushed
through with scrutiny the independence
of the civil service has been undermined
permanent secretaries sacked for
speaking truth to power and ministers
appointing their cronies as
non-executive directors and those in the
press who dare to criticize the
government get sidelined the government
tried to keep sections of the press out
of number 10 briefings their answer to
criticism channel 4 is to privatize it
whilst the bbc's reward for unbiased
public service broadcasting is the
license fee slashed
a free press a strong parliament an
independent judiciary and impartial
civil service are essential to a healthy
democracy
and this government has under
these institutions and it is shameful
this debate is essential to call a halt
to the dangerous trumpian assault on
everything we value in our british
democracy
this shouldn't be about conservatives
against labor every mp needs to ask
themselves can i have confidence in a
government that misleads with impunity
abuses office to reward friends with
jobs and lucrative contracts put
self-interest above the national
interest allows its party to accept cash
fare access influence and honours whose
members indulge in egregious lobbying or
sex bullying and sleaze scandals
any honorable or right honourable member
in good conscience walk through the
lobby and declare their confidence after
the litany of bad behaviors that have
marked this government's time in office
the answer must be no
[Applause]
sir bill wiggin
deputy speaker
i think i can be very confident in
predicting that we shall never again
here are prime ministers describe their
phenomenal electoral victory
as putting a blue ferret up the trouser
leg of the opposition
since entering office in 2019 on the
back of his historic election victory
the world has been turned on its head
and let us not lose sight of what the
government what has been thrown at the
government
since march 2020
we have lived through a once in a
century pandemic
the first major war in europe for a
generation
and worldwide economic turbulence
yet at every turn
this government and the prime minister
have put their back to the wheel and
gone to work for the british public
now of course
by their own admission
mistakes have been made
at every opportunity the prime minister
has shown contrition and a desire to get
on with a conservative agenda
however the mudslinging and the
relentless nature of politics and the
media eventually take its toll on even
the steeliest
character the labour party and some in
the media are glad to see the prime
minister go as we are losing a political
communicator and leader of historic
proportions
during the 1996 general election
i stood for burnley
and while i believe i did
as good a job as possible in restricting
the labor candidate to a majority of a
mere 17 062
i never thought that burnley would be a
conservative seat
nevertheless 22 years later and thanks
to this prime minister's leadership i am
proud to see that burnley has its first
conservative member of parliament since
1910 and a very good one at that
the british public put its overwhelming
faith in our prime minister
and his government
to get brexit done
finally we have escaped the grasp of the
european union's clutches and we have
our freedom
because this government made the right
calls at the right time during the
pandemic we are learning to live with
covid
over 39 million people have received a
booster jab across the uk we had the
fastest rollout in europe and were the
first to unlock and begin our recovery
on a smaller no less important scale
some years ago i brought forward a
private member's bill to allow
motorcycles to use bus lanes
the uh i will in a moment when i finish
this
the evidence showed that when
motorcyclists were in bus lanes
pedestrians were considerably more
careful and as a result people were no
longer hurt or seriously injured
now during his tenure as mayor of london
he heeded my call he made it happen and
as a result in london motorcyclists are
allowed in bus lanes i give way to the
honourable gentleman i'm very grateful
to the honourable member for giving way
we know that as foreign secretary
the prime minister managed to
slip his security detail
we don't know why
there's no officials there
does the honourable gentleman have any
concerns
what meetings the prime minister may
have had
as prime minister without officials or
security detail
but he's talking about i'm not going to
speculate
[Applause]
but probably not for the first time
and i'm sure he will agree that
motorcycling remains one of the best
ways to travel around the capital yes
i'll give way to the honourable jungler
but that will be it
okay uh on the television way does the
honourable member not agree that like
most of us individuals here
government is not perfect none of us are
certainly not myself and there are this
appears to be a genuine attempt to
change that approach otherwise it's not
my form to remind right honourable or
honorable members
that kindness and respect in this place
is a responsibility of every individual
member this debate must have that
underlying principle at its very core
none of us are perfect and if we were
this would be a very dangerous game to
be in because there would be very
quickly someone pointing out that we
were not and i think it's helpful for
our constituents to understand that it
is absolutely right for the opposition
to be able to call a confidence vote in
the government at any time and if they
made a mistake last week and therefore
were having it today like all of us they
are fallible too and we should be very
clear that that right is being defended
and he is right to insist that kindness
and respect are fundamental for this job
after all it's hard enough anyway
another aspect to this government and
its elect and its leader that cannot be
overshadowed is the reach and the
likability
my right honourable friend remains one
of the rare politicians who is on first
name terms with the public
this reflects a rapport with the public
which is frankly astonishing giving the
extent of smears from all corners of
society
and what many will never get their head
around is that the prime minister
remains immensely popular across the
country
he loves his children he is caring he is
loyal and my in-laws would agree as he
was their mp in henley yet despite all
the horrible things said about him he is
never rude back
many people would not have been able to
handle the vitriol he has experienced
over the last few years
but that is a testament to his character
and it is going to be a great shame that
he is going when he has done so much for
the free people of ukraine
and i hope we will all try to live up to
that example of protecting freedom
protecting freedom is so crucial and
that is why i'm proud to have supported
him and he is right to leave with his
head held high
[Applause]
[Music]
sir davey
speaker like so many of the british
people we on these liberal democrat
ventures have absolutely no confidence
in this whole conservative government
this government has plunged our country
our great country into three serious
crisis the cost of living crisis
the healthcare crisis and a political
crisis
before the prime minister was forced to
resign there was absolutely no plan to
tackle any of these crisis
and now the candidates succeed the prime
minister are proving comprehensively
they have no idea even of the scale of
these crisis let alone how to tackle
them
mr speaker i mentioned the scale of
these crisis
because it's shockingly evident that the
conservative party opposite
is totally out of touch with the
financial and health care catastrophes
facing millions of british families and
pensioners later this year
let's start with the cost of living
already families and pensioners are
struggling to pay their soaring energy
petrol and food bills inflation
accelerating away
energy bills alone up 700 pounds in
april with an even bigger rise
in october
so many of our questions are already
asking how they're supposed to pay next
month's bills
and their fear about winter's heating
bills is growing every day
understandably
millions of people are facing a finite
financial catastrophe over the next few
months
yet the party opposite seems blissfully
ignorant
in the so-called debates between the
leadership candidates there's this
massive elephant in the room called the
energy bill catastrophe
he had a total answer
any serious answer to that
the democrats showed what could be done
for months we've been calling for an
emergency cut in vat a tax cut say
families 600 pounds a year
instead this government's chosen to
raise taxes raising match insurance
freezing income tax thresholds and
hitting hard working families
making the crisis worse
not better
and then there's the health care crisis
health crisis used to occur for a few
weeks every winter
not with this conservative government
this prime minister's brought health
crises for winter autumn
summer and uh and spring
mandeville speaker
just look at the stats
a record six and a half million people
on hospital waiting lists
cancer treatments cancer treatment
targets missed by miles ambulance
response times with record long delays
but this government has ignored the
ambulance crisis hoping it goes away
it's failed to employ the gps the nhs
dentists and the care staff the british
people need and deserve
and now leadership candidates argue
about how much to slash the nhs budget
which brings me this mandatory speaker
to the political crisis
it would be easy to blame it all on the
prime minister
and surely he must certainly take a
large part of the blame
he has debased the high office of the
british prime minister and he has
shattered the public's trust in our
politics but he didn't act alone
for three years those on the benches
opposite have backed him to the hilt
when he was at that dispatch box telling
us there were no parties at number 10
or claiming crime had gone down when it
had gone up they were all there
nodding behind him
nodding along with every word of it
conservative mps defended the
indefensible and excuse the inexcusable
so madam deputy speaker
it's not just the prime minister we have
no compton them it's all of them
the people of cheshire and amisham show
they have no confidence in this
government when they elected my
honourable friend last year the people
of north shropshire showed they had no
confidence in this government in
december when they voted for another of
my honorable friends
and the people of devon show they have
no confidence in these conservatives
when they so wisely elected the new
member for tifton and hollington just
last month
so we just think it's time we gave
everyone across the country the chance
to have their say
and the chance to end this shameful
shambolic conservative government in a
general election
when members opposite
decide how to vote today i would urge
them to ask themselves these questions
do they really have confidence in the
government does raise
by over a thousand pounds per family in
the middle of a cost of living crisis
do they really have confidence in a
prime minister who was fined by the
police
for breaking his own law who forgot
about serious allegations against his
deputy chief whip
and who is now an investigation for
contempt by committee of this house
do they really have confidence in a
government that is running our nhs into
the ground and taking local communities
for granted
madame deputy speaker
i believe the british people have lost
competence in all of them
and if they had any decency left they'd
back this motion tonight
[Applause]
order mr speaker indicated that there
will be an informal limit of four
minutes that clearly isn't quite working
uh so we i i i'm not speaking with
reference to the leader of the liberal
democrats who is the leader of his party
is allowed as certain uh
um
leeway uh we now have to have a formal
limit of four minutes mike
in the majesties government because
faced with unprecedented challenges over
the past three years it's got far more
of the important ones right than it's
got wrong have to be mistakes of course
they have i'm not aware of any
government of any nation even in the
most benign of times that could claim
otherwise because these have not been
benign
times but on the big questions facing
the government our country is in a
better position now because the prime
minister has been in charge over the
past three years than it would have been
if the leader of the opposition had had
his way
on the decision to respect the
referendum result the prime minister
broke the deadlock over brexit that
threatened to leave the country
paralyzed with indecision while there is
still important issues to resolve it's
clear that any of the five conservative
candidates to replace him will continue
that work and secure brexit not reverse
it
we know what the leader of the
opposition wanted to do if he had become
credited secretary in 2019
another referendum to overturn the first
one we know that he promised labour
party members what he promised to become
leader he promised free movement across
the eu
and we know that he is now telling
voters that he wouldn't take us back
into the eu internal market but people
are bound to ask just who is he telling
the truth to
this government
and this prime minister
called it right
and going into a global pandemic this
government recognized that normal
procurement and distribution
distribution systems we're not going to
meet the need to get ppe to people who
needed it most urgently
and at the time the leader of the
opposition attacked the plans for having
too many checks for being too slow and
for not awarding contracts quickly
enough later that criticism was reversed
suddenly they were insufficient checks
and bureaucracy but again the government
called it right and struck the correct
balance
they put in place the biggest job
and business protection schemes in
british peacetime history to make sure
that our economy was able to build back
once the need for lockdown had passed 9
million workers wages paid nearly 3
million self-employed workers helped and
businesses right across our economy
supported if the lead of the opposition
had had his way and the right honourable
member for islington north's plans had
been put in place bankrupting the nation
we simply wouldn't have been able to
borrow the money for that emergency help
and back when a covid vaccine looked a
distant prospect the prime minister and
the government backed a range of
potential vaccines and a superb task
force with kate bingham which the
opposition decried as waste and cronyism
the opposition was wrong the prime
minister's right and britain got more
vaccines more quickly than any other
european country
i really don't have time and
and it was the prime minister's personal
intervention sending back early drafts
of the rollout strategy that brought
together the nhs armed forces and
private sector to get those vaccines out
more quickly than other large countries
and with russian troops invading one of
our european partners we can be proud of
this our prime minister who has done so
much to lead international support for
ukraine
it is simply not credible that imagine
to imagine that britain would have stood
as firmly against russian aggression if
it had been led
by a man whose response to an
assassination attempt on the streets of
salisbury had been to demand evidence be
sent to moscow
of course i would
and to the honourable gentleman did does
he think
that the right response to that
poisoning
was to fix a meeting
with a former intelligence agent of the
kgb
without officials without minutes
without any report to this house of what
the hell happened yeah yeah
[Music]
well gentlemen what the right response
was it was to coordinate the biggest
diplomatic response since the end of the
cold war where the prime minister as
foreign secretary got more diplomatic
responses than have been seen in decades
the prime minister has many achievements
of which he should be rightly proud
his successor will have a strong
foundation to build on thanks to the
decisions that he has taken over the
past three years and it's for these i
really shouldn't
it is for these and many other reasons
that this house should continue to have
confidence in her majesty's government
dame angela eagle
[Music]
speaker we do not currently have a
functioning government it imploded two
weeks ago with over 50 ministerial
resignations in 36 hours
their decision to render their own
government incapable of governing forced
the prime minister to concede that the
end was nigh
but he didn't resign
shamefully he was allowed to make over
60 new ministerial appointments to a
caretaker government
many of whom will only be ministers for
three months in this drift through a
national crisis
the prime minister has been told he must
be gone by the 5th of september that's
50 days from now
50 days in which the government is being
led by a disgraced prime minister and
parliament will be in recess
it's not in the interest of our country
or our democracy to allow this
discredited prime minister to squat in
downing street for one day longer he's a
security risk having admitted to
attending kgb agent alexander lebedev's
italian villa alone on route home from a
nato summit
he's trying to install more of his
cronies into strategic jobs before he
goes
he's ending his tenure in downing street
much as it began by going awol from
emergency cobra meetings preferring to
party at checkers instead
and there are rumors that he's planning
a bumper resignation honours list of 40
tory peers
such patronage should not be available
to a man driven from office in disgrace
by his own side
if it was carried this motion would
bring about a general election
it's voters not tory members who should
be given the chance to pass a verdict on
this catastrophic government and its
failures of probity and competence
of course the tories don't want to face
the voters yet they're hoping they can
ditch their third leader in a row and
crown a new prime minister without
bothering to ask the country
they prefer to have the next prime
minister chosen by their tiny and
completely unrepresentative party
membership
the very same people who chose the
current disgraced incumbent
barely three years ago
the tories hope they can get out of any
blame for giving a man they knew to be
unhol and wholly unfit for this great
office the keys to number 10 but they
can't tory and pisa as culpable as the
prime minister for the chaos and
catastrophe he's caused they gambled
with our democracy respect for the law
for truth for morality in public life
they lost and now the voters must judge
them
we're to believe the dangerous pictures
of the wannabe prime minister is still
in the leadership race the minuscule
tory membership appears to be obsessed
with fantasy promises of billions of
pounds of unfunded tax cuts and haunted
by the fear of so-called wokeness
what is crystal clear
is that they're not addressing any of
the real problems and challenges facing
this country after 12 years of tory
mystery
they've not addressed the cost of living
crisis facing millions of our fellow
citizens they've said nothing about
soaring levels of child poverty as they
buy with each other for who can concoct
the biggest fantasy tax cut they've left
the country weaker and more ill-prepared
for the future
their neglect has caused chaos in the
nhs the passport office the dvla at the
border in our schools and in the courts
and as the leadership race lumbers on
and more
2019 manifesto is ditched the tories are
shredding our constitution their
manifesto and their own mandate for
government and now they won't even
debate in public which is why we
urgently need a general election giving
evidence last
week john may just said of the cabinet
they were silent when they should have
spoken out and spoke only when their
silence became self-damaging the only
democratic way to respond to what has
happened is to have a general election
and have a general election now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
sir william
cash
i certainly most emphatically have
confidence in this government and no
confidence whatsoever in her majesty's
official opposition the liberal democrat
party the next scottish national party
nor any other rag tag on bobcat
first of all
i want to pay tribute to the prime
minister himself yeah who has led on all
the historic matters that he has carried
through so successfully what since he
became prime minister
mere three years ago
brexit
standing up for ukraine covered the
general election madame deputy speaker
was based on a manifesto which gave us a
great democratic majority and the labour
party a well-deserved drummond yeah yeah
on the handling of kobe for which he
nearly died himself and despite which
don't you dare speak like that
and and despite which with courage and
resilience he battled through
with astrazeneca and the scientific
expertise of our great scientists and
the support of our government under this
prime minister
then there is ukraine
and putin's brutal and unprovoked
aggression and the murder and killing of
innocent citizens not to mention even
russian soldiers sent to fight on false
pretenses
the prime minister of this country has
led the world yeah yeah
then there is brexit on which he led a
democratic victory in 2019
endorsing the vote of the british people
in 2016
freeing us from the subjugation of the
european union
other than the unfinished business of
northern ireland
now
being addressed in the committee stage
of the protocol bill
with the majority of 74 on second
reading
brexit itself
with the freedoms generated by leading
the laws of the european union and the
means to unleash the potential of the
british people and their business
their innovation and their worldwide
commercial ambitions will create new
horizons in our economic history
all this is based on stable economic
foundations
the fact is that if you look at the
unemployment rate in the other member
states
our unemployment
now we're out is 3.8 germany 5.3 italy 8
spain 13 the eurozone
is imploding and on life support
all these problems of the cost of living
were induced by global
uncontrollable external forces causing
inflation throughout the western world
underneath all the strident rantings of
the party opposite this government has
succeeded when on every count they would
have
completely failed miserably
the essential foundations of sovereignty
and democracy have now been re-embedded
in our national dna
the success cannot be taken away from
the prime minister
and it never will be when the history
books are written
job vacancies are now at a mere 1.3
million
in in this country come far far better
than in the other member states
the g7 and similar countries are
affected in a similar way
thanks to this prime minister and this
gov this government and this
party we have made a success of one of
the greatest revolutions in british
constitutional history certainly since
we entered
in 1973 and stretching back over 400
years i have confidence in this
government because it has achieved and
the people on the other side of this
house i've failed every single time
they've ever been given an opportunity
to do it and they'll do so again
[Applause]
stewart mark on mcdonald's
well what a man to follow madam er
deputy speaker
because uh well i'm not sure fran and
allah here quite agree with me on that
actually but let me say madame deputy
speaker we're here debating
a motion of no confidence in the
government
but as has been said by other speakers
before me we don't have
a government it's a government in name
only it's essentially now
a form of organized tory hooliganism
that squats in these offices of state
that squats in these departments and
squats most of all
in downing street
and
one of the canards that is often
advanced if the member wants to go out
in his feet and intervene he's more than
welcome i'm happy to have that extra 60
seconds from him
but the canard is often advanced by
members opposite indeed you wouldn't
know that we're only having this debate
because members opposite wielded the
knife on their leader just a couple of
weeks ago but the canard is that the
prime minister quote gets the big calls
right
well let's examine that proposition
indeed the honorable in fact i think a
few honorable members opposite have been
asked did he really get a big call right
when post salisbury
straight after a nato summit he went to
a palazzo in italy of a former kgb
agent was that him getting the big calls
right to not even have the decency
to do that properly with security and
then log it with his department when he
was foreign secretary that's before he
even got to downing street did he get
all the big calls right when he was
partying all over the place and our
constituents had to adhere to the rules
as strictly as they did indeed it
resulted in him being the only prime
minister the only prime minister to have
received a fixed penalty notice whilst
in office well i always thought madam
madame dickinson
speaker i i have i have witnessed the
scottish conservative party like you at
close quarters over the years and i
always thought if you go back to the
days of his old pal the late sir teddy
taylor that telemetry of my constituency
he believed in law and order and he sits
there decrying anyone who draws
attention to the fact that we have a
criminal in downing street who has the
keys for another five weeks in office
happily
is he aware that the lord chief justice
himself in a case on fixed penalty
nurses when the payment was made within
the 28 days said it was not a crime that
he couldn't be prosecuted and that he
left the court without a staying on his
character
well well the honorable the honorable
the honourable gentleman has educated me
because i did not know that but it
doesn't change the facts
facts are chills that wanna ding madam
deputy speaker and those are indeed the
facts the prime minister has prove
presided over a shambles what was
witnessed two weeks ago in this very
building and not so far from here was a
government in meltdown and yet we're
asked to believe we're asked to believe
that somehow
all of the mps and ministers and pps's
and trade envoys who resigned got it
wrong and somehow this prime minister is
still fit for office well nothing says
that quite like the acres of empty green
benches on the government side of the
house tonight so whilst they may well
it's a government motion it's a
government motion brought forward by the
prime minister himself and isn't it
telling that none of the leadership
candidates have turned up to defend him
here tonight one can one can only one
could only imagine that several of those
who've come here if the gentleman wishes
to get to his feet i'm happy to be
educated once again
he's making a fantastically fascicle
speech but i'm enjoying it immensely oh
he's a little bit rich to have a go at
candidates when there's an election
actually open now for not being here at
this very point there is a fair place
and he knows this process he's been
longer here than i have so this is a
what six hour debate i think it's fair
to give some courtesies in this house
interventions are best made on your feet
man i'm deputy speaker and the honorable
gentleman showed that with great grace
this evening but as far as this is
viewed indeed in scotland from what
we've heard not just from the leadership
candidates but from the prime minister
himself indeed he was at great pains to
name the various constituencies that
he's big blue tory ferret had paraded
through all through the red wall it's
worth noting in scotland his party
continues to go backwards anytime that
the electorate face a ballot paper in
their constituencies the tories have
never won an election in scotland since
the 1950s and the idea that we're
frightened of any of these contenders
now is for the birds they will again
lose more elections in scotland and that
is why because of the chaos that has
actually started from david cameron it's
not all the current incumbent at number
10's fault let's be honest i can see the
right honourable gentleman at least
agrees with me on that one but all of
the chaos that has flowed from that
referendum in 2016 to now has only made
the case has only made the case for a
strengthening for a strengthening of
scottish democracy for which i know the
right honourable gentleman takes
seriously there will be a referendum on
scottish independence he can shake his
head as much as he likes the reason that
there will be one madam deputy speaker
the reason there will be one is because
like many of the members opposite the
public are free to change their minds
they are free to give a government in
edinburgh a mandate as they did in 2011
to ask that question on scottish
independence again we rejected this
rancid squalid brexit that he sits there
smiling all about and that is how we
reverse it in scotland labour have shown
us there's no root to do it via
westminster the only way to do it is for
scots to take their future into their
own hands create that path back into the
european community where we belong and
we will do that firstly with our
independence referendum in 2023 and i
look forward to the scottish people
voting for it with enthusiasm
[Applause]
gareth bacon
thank you madam deputy speaker i rise to
declare my confidence in her majesty's
government
and there are a myriad of substantial
reasons for doing so but i'm going to
focus on just three because the time
allowed to me the first of course
is ending the brexit impasse the dead
parliament of 2017 to 19 has shown
itself so completely incapable of doing
yeah under the leadership of my right
noble friend the prime minister the
conservative party won a landslide
victory at the 2019 general election
when i had the privilege of being
elected for the first time to represent
my constituents in orpington
it is an undeniable
fact that the significant reason for the
national result was the mandate to
deliver on the largest democratic
exercise in this country's history an
exercise that had been hitherto thwarted
by arrogant elites some of whom i see
sitting opposite me this evening
yeah but on the 31st of january
on the 31st of january 2020 her
majesty's government delivered on the
will of the people and we left the
european union yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah now the labour party
madam deputy speaker claimed that a
conservative government would not
achieve a brexit trade deal well her
majesty's government announced on the
24th of december 2020 that the eu and
britain had agreed a post-brexit trade
deal ending months of disagreement
a clear manifesto commitment that the
previous dead parliament had failed to
deliver on have been completed within a
few weeks of the election
and in the months that followed the
government announced more than 70 trade
agreements with countries all around the
world so that's achievement number one
madame dr speaker i'll now move on to
achievement number two
shortly after we left the european union
the worst pandemic in a century hit the
entire world
her majesty's government put its arms
around the people at great pace and
under enormous pressure
the government introduced a
comprehensive package of support for
individuals and businesses
component parts of the support deals
such as the photo scheme saved millions
of people
from being made redundant when
businesses could not trade due to the
spread of the virus and although our
economy was on life support it was kept
alive thanks to the actions taken by
this government
as a direct result
of decisions taken by my honourable
friend the prime minister this country
was amongst the first to begin to emerge
from the pandemic because her majesty's
government made the right call when it
came to the vaccine
thanks to the government's quick action
to secure the most promising vaccine
doses in advance more than 120 million
doses were administered in the first
year in the uk alone
now however it should be noted that the
leader of the labour party wanted
britain to remain within the european
medicine agency which would have delayed
the roll out of the vaccine
countries in the ema were much slower in
vaccine production and roll out than the
uk
had labor remained in power the vaccine
success experienced in this country
would not have occurred at anything like
speed with potentially dire consequences
her majesty's government made the right
call when it came to reopening the
economy last year something which of
course the labour party disagreed with
time after time madam deputy speaker
senior labour figures called for the
maintenance and even an extension of
restrictions yeah the leader of the
opposition even said that he would vote
for a circuit breaker lockdown over
christmas and then days later pretended
that he had never backed a christmas
restriction had he been in power madame
did you speak it would have been less
capped in hindsight and more major
catastrophe
[Music]
[Applause]
finally it is this government and this
prime minister
which has led to the west rallying the
international support for the ukraine
so in conclusion madame deputy speaker
her majesty's government has kept our
country safe
it has led the world in response to the
first ground war in the european
continent since the second world war and
it has got brexit done
it is therefore
patently obvious that this house should
have confidence in her majesty's
government and i will be supporting the
motion
[Applause]
jess phillips thank you madam deputy
speaker it's really unusual to be in
here listening to all this praising of
the prime minister from the people who
just got rid of him um so it's just an
unusual thing i just wonder whether
you're having buyer's remorse um there
is one thing about why our prime
minister was got rid of very in very
heartfelt letters uh by the people
opposite that has been since the
leadership um
uh hustings and everything have started
completely forgotten as if it didn't
happen and the reason i don't have any
confidence in the government and the
reason i don't have any confidence in
the conservative party is because of the
dreadful record they have overseen on
sexual harassment and violence within
their own ranks
since i was elected to this house two
members of the conservative party have
gone to prison for perpetrating sexual
crimes in one of those cases i
repeatedly
begged various people with power whether
it was the chief whip on on this on
their side of the house to intervene to
stop to not give him the whip back
telling them how serious the accounts i
had heard
every single time it was ignored
also
the
if you'd like to intervene on me i'm
more than happy to explain the very fine
details
um also a victim of child sexual abuse
came forward to the conservative party
and said that they had been abused by
the candidate in wakefield to which the
conservative party lost the complaint or
it went somewhere
he was then elected he is now in prison
for sexual crimes
this is deeply serious the member for
dellen uh madame deputy speaker i have
informed all the people i will be
mentioning that i will be mentioning
them i should imagine there's some
people checking their inboxes right now
um
that
the member for delhi was cleared by the
conservative party's processes
and then the prime minister
is toppled
because he promoted somebody who he knew
had undertaken sexually harmful
behaviors so while you're all everybody
in here is now dancing on the head of a
pin about how great he was and he got
all the big calls right remember the
reason that every one of the people in
here wrote those letters
where in every single one of the
candidates if if the justice secretary
would like to intervene i'm more than
happy to take it um
the
he's saying it's totally would he like
to get to his feet and tell me what i've
said that is total rubbish no should i
tell him what's total rubbish the rape
statistics that he has overseen that is
what is total rubbish and it is not a
surprise when his political party turns
a blind eye i give way does she
recognize
the fact that in the last year the
volume of rape convictions has increased
by two-thirds that's simple yes or no
the convictions
but how is the charging secretary of
state again i'm happy to take the
intervention has this charging gone up
or down we currently have a rape rate of
1.3
of rapes that come forward are charged
and it doesn't surprise me when the
institution that is currently in
government turns a constant
blind eye
to sexual misdemeanors of the people so
there's a lot of people have mentioned
anti-semitism in this debate today
because you're all desperate to make
this about there being something wrong
with the labour party however
when when the labour party was holding a
leadership election every single
candidate was asked what will you do to
stamp out anti-semitism and rightly so
it is absolutely vital that we were held
to account
so what what did
any one of the candidates do when
the the member i can't remember where
you know
pinch you by now and picture my name
nate
i can't remember where or order order
order order i have given the honourable
lady quite a lot of leeway we are here
discussing matters that are or will be
sub-judicea perhaps and and i think the
honorable lady knows what it just let's
guide in a different direction
like to know what
the chancellor of the exchequer of the
time did when the member for tamworth
was given the position i'd like to know
what the foreign secretary did
did they all sit back
i wouldn't have
i would never have sat back i want to
know what every one of the candidates
who wants to be the prime minister did
when that happened and i want to know
what the conservative party is going to
do about its institutional problem where
it cannot deal appropriately with
complaints
independently about sexual harassment i
have absolutely no confidence
chris clarkson
[Applause]
thank you madam deputy speaker um
today's motion is on whether or not we
have confidence in the government and
obviously i will be speaking in favor of
that but i do want to register my
exasperation with the way that we
arrived at having to introduce this
particular motion after the botched
stunt from the party opposite last week
by attempting to table a vote no
confidence in the prime minister they
were seeking to do away with
constitutional precedent and decades of
convention
whatever their personal animus towards
the prime minister and i've listened to
the speeches and i can tell it runs very
very deeply
and the office is bigger than any one
person and the institutions around it
our constitution are bigger still
to seek to upend that in a fit of petty
spy just shows how irresponsible and
deeply unfit the leader of the
opposition is to lead a man who should
know better a man who as a lawyer does
know better but a man who simply cannot
do better
this is the mother of parliament not a
sixth form debating society
however
that's not what this debate's about and
i appreciate it's a popular one so i
wanted to touch briefly on why i'll be
supporting the government tonight
those on this side were elected an
ambitious manifesto which was not just
about brexit as some would like to claim
it was also about how we use that
opportunity to change the way that our
country is working because frankly for a
very long time in a great number of
places it simply has not been
areas like mine were left in bay it's
written off put in the too hard basket
subjected to their own passive form of
managed decline and that isn't right
that can't be the case that all the
talent and all the abilities clustered
in one part of the country we know it
isn't so why should all the opportunity
be focused in a postage stamp size area
in our country
our manifesto promised to address that
and we've already made great strides
that job has been undoubtedly
complicated by the pandemic which is why
nobody's manifesto contained it but it
has been necessary to do extremely
difficult things
but it was years of making those tough
choices since 2010 restoring our public
finances that enabled us to put our arms
around the nation at the darkest of
times
there will jaz would be those who want
to talk down the pandemic response but
the simple fact is that this country
went further and faster than most to
protect vaccinate and unlock
it wasn't all that long ago the members
opposite we're demanding that we emulate
the eu or new zealand
and a host of other countries only for
them to be grappling with surging
infections and repeated lockdown
measures
madam deputy speaker i've always
believed that leveling up or whatever we
want to call it is about different
things in different areas and for me in
hayward and middleton that meant
improving educational opportunities and
transport links seemingly simple things
that will open doors currently just out
of reach of so many
in my borough alone around 130 million
pounds was injected into the local
economy to protect lives and livelihoods
at the height of the pandemic
and despite a genuine fight to stop
rochdale's labour council siphoning most
of that into their reserves we got the
money to the people who needed it
during my first 18 months as an mp i
closed more cases than my labour
predecessor did in her five
that's with the level of intensity this
government has put into supporting the
country and the amount of disinterest
shown by my predecessor and her party
but now as we emerge from the pandemic
what next rochdale borough has bids in
for 14 million pounds of leveling up
funding greater manchester has been
allocated 98 million pounds from the
share prosperity fund in addition to
over a billion year mark to improve
public transport which for me is a game
changer over a million has been given to
cultural recovery in the borough and the
government's designated as one of its
priority educations investment areas
with a share of over 40 million pounds
despite everything that's happened in
the past few years we're getting on with
the job
it's been i've been extremely proud on
these benches the past two and a half
years and i genuinely do believe that
what we've done has been with the best
of intentions to make this country a
true partnership for people all of them
engaged in the common endeavor all of us
equally able to achieve we're willing to
put the work in and that is why we'll be
voting confidence in the government
[Applause]
chris bryant thank you madam deputy
speaker no i don't have confidence in
this government because they have
manifestly failed to govern efficiently
or effectively they wasted billions on
fraudulent covert loans on unusable ppe
and on a test and trace system that
never ever worked and they have
completely mismanaged the passport
office the dvla and the railways no i
don't have confidence in this government
because they lied about brexit and they
haven't got brexit done
no i don't have confidence in this
government because they haven't got any
of the big calls right when we were
warning when i was warning about putin's
russia the prime minister said the days
of tanks rolling across europe was over
and he cut our army by ten thousand
when kobit started they failed to
protect people in care homes sending
thousands unnecessarily to early graves
when everyone issued warnings about
inflation the prime minister said that
it was nothing to get worried about no i
don't have confidence in this government
because a massive shortage of personnel
and skills is holding britain back
asparagus and courgettes plowed back
into the field strawberries left to rot
pig carcasses destroyed all while
british families rely on food banks and
worst of all most shameful of all nhs
hospitals running food banks for their
staff
many schools have no applications at all
for teaching posts especially in key
subjects like science maths and modern
languages no i don't have confidence in
this government because they refuse to
put magnitsky sanctions in place for
years because they still haven't tackled
dodgy russian money and london's massive
money money laundering industry because
they failed to take putin's initial
invasion of ukraine seriously enough in
2014 and because their delight in
putin's bling emboldened putin no i
don't have confidence in this government
because they're obsessed with all the
wrong things they spend more time and
energy protecting statues than
protecting women from domestic abuse
they deliberately drive wedges between
people over gender identity and trans
rights and ignore the fact that their
own equality minister resigned because
he thought the government was creating a
hostile environment for lgbt people
which is why he should be ashamed to
defend this government no i don't have
government i don't have confidence in
this government because they have no
plan for the nhs or social care
england has a backlog of 6.6 million
patients and that excludes patients
multiple treatments and no it isn't all
to do with covid we had a 4.8 million
backlog before the pandemic they
promised but
he's doing a point of volume sorry
divorder chris started waited directly
wait by the way
i do hope that this isn't i
really do
feel it's quite bad if we have points of
order that disrupt debates the honorable
gentleman has had a chance to speak i'm
not sure that he tried to intervene on
the underworld gentleman but go ahead
with his point of order the honourable
gentleman just pointed at me and said
that's why he should be ashamed is that
in order
uh
yeah well yes if that's his opinion um
then
he has said he's he
if he did he tried did you try to
intervene
no he didn't that would be the
appropriate that that would be the
appropriate thing to do
the chair has said consistently about
temperance of language to say that my
right my honourable friend from having
middleton as a lgbt man should be
ashamed to find this government i don't
think fits within the ruling that the
chair has given could you just clarify
for the purpose of the house whether
it's temperate to language
this is not
a point of order
first of all secondly
the speaker
and the chairman of ways and means and
myself have all said that we should try
to conduct this debate
in reasonable terms and i think we just
all need to
calm down
and discuss the important matters that
are before the house
chris bryant thank you madam deputy
speaker no i don't have confidence in
this government because they play fast
and loose with numbers they boast that
they're recruiting twenty thousand more
police but they cut police by twenty
thousand they boast of a single tax cut
now but forget that they've increased
taxes fifteen times in two and a half
years giving us the highest tax burden
for 70 years they boasted the kobe
vaccination as if they personally
developed it in the downing street
kitchen but actually france germany
italy portugal and singapore have higher
vaccination rates than us and wales
managed it faster than england no i
don't have confidence in this government
because not even conservative mps really
have confidence in this government they
know it's a massive conceit an organized
hypocrisy a house built on sand and the
fishers run deep they're not even very
good at being conservatives these days
tearing up conventions and the
constitution like student
revolutionaries of course that's not how
they'll vote today oh no they wouldn't
dare risk a general election but even as
they troop through the lobbies to
indicate yes they do have confidence in
the government they will be privately
plotting its demise they will be making
themselves look foolish today i don't
mind that but they can't take the
british public for fools as well
[Music]
i thank the prime minister for his
dedication to the united kingdom of
great britain and northern ireland his
aspiration for all in this country and
his expectation that we can achieve
great things as individuals and as a
country
this conservative government working as
a team has delivered
hundreds of achievements over the past
two and a half years
it has delivered and continues to
deliver on the people's priorities
brexit for starters in march 2020 the
country faced an alarming health crisis
the covert pandemic
and something which those opposite had
conveniently forgotten about
this government has taken decisive
action to shield the public from the
worst effects of the pandemic and the
war in ukraine and it is very easy to
criticize but far
far more difficult to make tough and
hard decisions
we have delivered the biggest reforms to
our railways in 25 years with simpler
modern fares and reliable services for
passengers we've begun the accessing
process to join the comprehensive
and progressive transpo pacific
partnership giving uk businesses access
to one of the world's largest and most
dynamic
free trade areas we hosted cop 26 in
glasgow last year helping to drive
ambitious climate change action around
the world and we saw the world leading
environment act passed ensuring that the
environment as at the heart of this
government's agenda the agriculture act
the police and crime sentencing and
courts act the building safety act the
skills and post-16 education act the
nationality and borders bill we've seen
the plan for jobs upskilling and
reskilling our focus on education giving
every people in england a funding booth
so all children have the same
opportunities to succeed we've invested
in leveling up parts of the country that
have been long overlooked and neglected
including the leveling up fund and the
town's fund deals hastings received 24
point million leveraging another 85
million in private sector funding i
could go on
i'd like to find the honourable lady for
giving away on that point and she
mentions the talents fund which is uh
would she agree with me he's going to
transform and regenerate regenerate the
towns
and
cities that have been left behind by the
labour in the past
my honorable friend for his intervention
and completely agree with him this is
why the previous conservative government
had the northern powerhouse to try and
lift
those people left behind for generations
by the labor party
it is a fundamental principle of our
constitution that any government must
retain the confidence of the legislature
that is us
the conservative party won an 80-seat
majority we may have slightly reduced
that majority now but this government
operates effectively
as votes on legislation in the last
couple of weeks alone prove
healthy majority votes in favor of the
government backing the government the
prime minister may have lost the
personal confidence of some of his mps
but he has not lost the legislature
mandate
i pity those on the opposition ventures
they have resorted to the petty low of
personality politics because they have
nothing else
so with this prime minister gone
what will they do
we can feel their panics seeping across
the woods
their
hate fueled moralistic posturing
has made them all vulnerable
government continues to function as a
strong team
and i have full confidence in it to
deliver the priorities of the people and
businesses
living in my constituency as well as as
as well as the country
this on this side of the house
we keep calm and we carry on in the
british room
[Applause]
tommy shepard
[Applause]
the most disturbing aspect about this
entire debate
is that the prime minister is still in
office
after all the lies the rule breaking the
defense of sexual predators and after
his own cabinet turns on him he is still
in office
now clearly this chamber has no
confidence in the prime minister but the
reason why i have no comp in the moment
the reason why i have no confidence in
the prime minister in this conservative
party is because they have enabled this
delusion and they continue to enable it
in his mind he thinks he has done no
wrong he probably thinks that he is even
the victim i'll take the intervention
thank you i thank the honourable
gentleman does he know of any other
parties represented in this chamber
whose leaders tried to protect sexual
predator and are still imposed
i'm sorry i didn't i i didn't i didn't
actually hear what the gentleman said so
uh my apologies
does the honourable gentleman know of
any other parties represented in this
chamber whose leader is still imposed
after protecting the sexual predator
no i do not
but but but but if but if they're aware
if they're if they're aware they should
certainly be
investigated and if the honourable
gentleman is trying to say something
perhaps he should say it and not be
quite so coy and and insinuate things
now what is even more concerning is of
course the manner in which the prime
minister's successor is being selected
and what started out as a sort of
political beauty pageant has become a
carnival of reactionary ideas as these
contestants buy with each other to see
who can be the most right wing and the
reason for that of course is simple is
because they are not appealing to the
conservative parliamentary party they
are appealing to a narrow and
narrow-minded section of the electorate
quite unlike the people amongst whom
they live the conservative party
membership how else could we explain
that as the country burns not a single
candidate has anything to say about the
climate emergency
how else can we explain that they are
talking about tax cuts on business
profits
rather than action to help ordinary
families with the cost of living crisis
now there will be members of the party
opposite who will hope that this is just
an aberration and actually these things
will disappear once the contest is over
and some of this economic illiteracy and
particularly the dribble about small
states and tax cuts will pass and go
into history well i will take your
information yeah i'd just like to point
out madam deputy speaker for the benefit
of the house and the honorable gentleman
that in fact earlier today every single
one of the candidates spoke and was
questioned at length by the conservative
environment network precisely on the
issues which he has just described
my point by the deputy speaker is that
when they set out their stall to you
this was not on their agenda this is not
something that they chose to put in
their prospectus because they know who
they're appealing to and it is worrisome
in the extreme
that people who ought to know better are
massaging prejudices amongst the
conservative party membership in order
to gain political office now some will
hope that this will disappear once this
election is over and much of the drivel
about tax cuts and small states and the
economic and literacy that comes with it
will pass away
i say this there is a worrying trend
here that some of these ideas may gain
traction and they may change public
policy
and i am concerned that the party
opposite is attempting to do that and
change public policy in this country
without consulting the electorate and if
it does that i believe that that would
be undemocratic and it would be
illegitimate madam deputy speaker when
it comes to scotland i am also concerned
i don't expect any new conservative
leader or this conservative government
to support a scottish independence
referendum but i do expect i do expect a
degree of civility and respect when it
comes to appreciating scottish public
opinion and it is distressing that what
we have seen from quite a number of
these candidates and what now seems to
mark the character of the government is
to actually ignore that and override it
hence we get statements about how the uk
government thinks that it needs to save
the scottish people from the snp led
government in edinburgh
what a monstrous contempt that is on the
people who elected that government just
14 months ago
surely it is not too much to expect that
there should be some dialogue some
respectful conversation because if there
is not
then that in itself will ensure the
destruction of this union
but this attitude is fueling
the campaign in scotland for an
alternative and we come here mandated by
the communities that sent us here to say
that people in scotland want another
choice on whether they should be an
independent country and it is their
right their democratic rights to have
that aspiration and to demand that it be
listened to and we will not be going
away we will keep coming we will keep
demanding and the more this government
for whom i have no confidence refuses
the more the argument for the
alternative a new independent country
will gain grant and i say to the
conservative party and to the
conservative government scotland clearly
has no confidence in you
but everything that you are doing makes
scotland believe that there is a better
alternative to come here
andy carter thank you very much madam
deputy speaker uh following the
honourable member for anna maurice one
of his colleagues uh just a few moments
ago talked about tory hulig is
hooliganism
the definition of hooliganism is the snp
trying to smash up the united kingdom
that's hooliganism
the motion we're debating tonight
asks does this house have confidence
in her majesty's government
absolutely yes we have confidence
in this government madam deputy speaker
why do i say this what this government
is delivering for british people is
delivering for my constituents in
warrington south
we've left the european union
we've invested and innovated in life
sciences to deliver a vaccine rollout
we've supported families and businesses
during the worst health crisis for 100
years with the furlough program we've
lifted restrictions allowing our economy
to get back to business we've supported
ukraine in a way that most other
european countries have failed to do we
put billions of support into families as
the long tail of kovid affects the cost
of living this government absolutely is
backing the people of this country and
our first duty as members of parliament
is always to our constituents and the
respective areas we are honored to
represent in this place so what have the
government been doing for the last two
and a half years for warrington well
leveling up for transport
warrington benefiting from 42 million
pounds of government investment
replacing our entire fleet of uh buses
with 120 new zero emission electric
buses tackling the problems that we face
with uh environmental issues ensuring we
have a cleaner uh and better air quality
improving uh services for local people
and reducing the cost what are we doing
in terms of schools well just last week
i had a message from the principal of uh
of pence high school john carlin who
said how thrilled he was to receive six
million pounds from this government to
rebuild his school something he's been
trying to achieve for the last ten years
a six million pound rebuilding program
finally will mean students in pancake
will get the facilities that they
deserve
and in march this year
i was delighted to welcome the prime
minister to warrington to open a brand
new scan center at the warrington
hospital funded with five million pounds
from this government
it's a fantastic addition delivering a
new mri and ct scanner
and reconfiguring the imaging streets
and facilities meaning that the backlogs
that we faced as a result of cobit have
almost now entirely been removed and
while this government puts in place
policies and funding to help
constituents in warrington south with a
set with a labour warrington borough
council whose priorities appear to be
building huge logistics centers on the
green belt
and introducing terrible low traffic
neighborhoods that simply increase the
amount of congestion in our town madam
deputy speaker for all the talk from the
opposition parties of a general election
let's just remind ourselves that we have
a parliamentary system not a
presidential one we are elected on a
manifesto to level up those areas of the
country which for too long have felt
unnoticed and have been left behind and
i'm incredibly proud to represent my
home area in this place and i'm proud to
work with this conservative government
that has done so much to benefit
constituencies like warrington south and
tonight i will be voting to support this
government in today's
[Music]
lynn
motion
grateful i'm deputy speaker i decided to
have a quick look at this tory
government's record in order to prepare
for this debate i found that child
poverty was up by 300 000 since 2010.
860 000 children according to
government's own records don't know
where the next meal is coming from and
that's all before we factor in the cruel
cut to universal credit or this year's
inflation rate so no i have no
confidence
in this government crime is up 18
prosecutions down 18
and that's just the last three years
less than six percent of offenses lead
to a charge and that is a record low so
no
i have no confidence in this government
the prime minister promised 40 new
hospitals where are they ambulance
weights are going through the roof every
single ambulance service is in critical
incident people having a heart attack or
a stroke are waiting on average 50
minutes for an ambulance and we know for
many it's far longer one patient waited
24 hours in an ambulance before a space
in the hospital was found these weights
are deadly so no
i have no confidence in this government
but let's get to the man in downing
street he spent the last past years as
he spent his whole life corrupting and
destroying confidence in everything he
touches it's not just about the parties
the law breaking or whether he misled
this house it's his casual approach to
our democracy and our society he's spent
the last six months pretending
everything's going great and we know it
ain't
inflation is skyrocketing the economy is
on the verge of recession and what's the
plan to deal with the root causes of
this we have workforce shortages
blighting out nhs all our public
services and much of the private sector
too we have massive trade problems
linked to the mismanagement of the tory
brexit but all the leadership of the
party opposite know how to do is to
pretend immigration is somehow the
problem and bashing the eu is some kind
of solution well it ain't
madam deputy speaker the tory party have
finally done the right thing but frankly
it's too late and it's superficial
there's not going to be real change the
tory record of destruction
division and chaos continues the
country's boiling but their leadership
candidates won't credibly address
climate change they've said little to
nothing and apparently i think they must
live on a different planet
all they can manage to argue about
against actually is the tax hikes that
they voted for just weeks ago and when
they ain't doing that they're trying to
divide our communities based on
frivolous nonsense we'd be better off if
they talked about stopping climate
hitting or how to stop the nhs falling
apart but that doesn't seem to match the
priorities are tory donors so do i have
confidence in this government hell no
the truth is our country will only be
able to recover once a lot of them are
out of office and for that we need a
general election let's get on with it
tom randall
hugh madame deputy speaker um the
manifesto on which this government was
elected is entitled get brexit done
unleash britain's potential and the
first part of that has been achieved it
has been difficult and protracted but we
got there and i congratulate my right
honourable friend prime minister in
achieving perhaps the most significant
single piece of constitutional change in
the post-war era yeah and then we'll see
for example unrest in places like
catalonia i think that we sometimes do
not give ourselves enough credit at this
country's ability to affect change
peacefully smoothly and considering the
far-reaching implications of brexit at
some pace the prime minister achieved
this and while his premiership is ending
sooner than many would have liked
consider than i would have liked his
place in history is undoubtedly assured
and he has begun to unleash britain's
potential so i welcome the creation of
an east midlands freeport that will
create up to 60 000 jobs in the region
made possible by brexit i welcome the
government's ambitious vaccination
policy made possible by brexit and i
further welcome the over two dozen
police officers on the streets of
gedling the plans to overhaul the
queen's medical center and city
hospitals in nottingham and the
increased school funding and giggling
made possible thanks to the sound
finances only a decade of conservative
government
can provide this is my right angle
friend the prime minister's legacy and
it's a legacy that will be taken forward
uh in the remainder of this parliament
now the leader of the opposition has
instigated this motion today this
confidence motion
[Music]
in order and if it and were it to fail
there will be a clamor for a general
election so what is the leader of the
opposition's european policy
for starters he is the man who said no
the man who was happy to tell the people
of gedling that you may have voted to
leave the european union but i'm going
to ask you to do it again
to him the good folk of godling had put
their ex in the wrong place on the
ballot paper and were to be admonished
and to correct their mistake
the leading opposition is seeking to
look like a prime minister in waiting
and to establish his european
credentials this week he's gone to the
continent he's turned up in berlin where
the bundestag is in recess
he's committed what many consider us
faux pas by recording a party political
video at a holocaust memorial and in
that video declared that he wants the
labour party to follow in the footsteps
of the german spd
or given madam national speaker the
sbd's position in the opinion polls has
fallen by fifth in the last three months
i wish him well in those endeavors
there are currently as i speak five
contenders for the leadership of the
conservative party almost many as
contenders as there are for the labour
party
and one of the things that those members
those contenders for the conservative
leadership have in common is that none
of them served or would serve in the
shadow cabinet led by the right
honourable member for islington north
hostile for nato nato calling for
collaboration with russia after a
russian chemical attack and a proponent
of a reckless economic agenda
the prospect of a labour government led
by the right honourable member for
islington north scared people in gatling
at the last election and notwithstanding
the many achievements of this government
of which there are many it is surely
inconceivable that anyone would have
preferred would have placed greater
confidence in the alternative government
that might have been elected in 2019 to
take us through the pandemic the
brexit and the war in ukraine and say
madame deputy speaker i was supporting
tonight's motion because i have
confidence in the program of this
government i have confidence in the
cabinet i have confidence in a manifesto
and i have confidence that the labour
party remains unfit for government
dave dugan
thank you madam deputy speaker while i
certainly do not have confidence in this
cobble together bottom of the barrel
government and if we're supposed to be
voting in here tonight about whether or
not we've got confidence the people out
there will surely be asking is this some
sort of rhetorical question because when
you add all the opposition mps then you
add in all the ministers who have
resigned and you add in all the tory mps
who voted against the prime minister in
the vote of confidence i think we know
where parliament sits on this prime
minister and it's not a positive report
card in any way shape or form and
scotland never took a minute of this
prime minister seriously i'm testament
to that fact when they went to the
country in 2019 anger said no we're not
going to have a tour and p we're going
to have an smp mp in westminster
speaking up for the values of fairness
and opportunity and underscoring the
mandate that we have for an independence
referendum and it will happen i can
assure you of that i won't miss this
prime minister talking up
gaslighting the people of these islands
about the uk economy he makes it sound
like it's a land of milk and honey where
there's 2.2 trillion pounds worth of
sovereign debt in the uk's name and
let's be really clear when this
government came to power there was 0.8
trillion pounds of sovereign debt it's
getting on for three times that and that
0.8 took nearly 100 years to build up
this government have nearly tripled it
in 12 years the government have lost
complete control of the economy and the
term working poor let's forget should be
a contradiction in terms but it isn't
not in the uk where you can go to work
every two people in one house go to work
for four hours a week and still not have
enough money to put food on the table he
clocks himself in the nhs in the most
shameless unedifying way possible it's
absolutely important and then there's
phantom numbers about building new
hospitals while all the while people
can't get access to an ambulance or get
their way down a waiting list for an
operation and he shamelessly exploits
the uk armed forces who should be above
politics and have been dragged
mercilessly into it by this prime
minister and his cronies in the cabinet
he's got a a a thousand cut to the to
the army under his watch nuclear weapons
are getting and the delivery systems are
getting on for consuming a sixth of the
armed forces budget they've cut the e7
wedge deal program to three and the ajax
five and a half billion pound debacle
has been rumbling on for the entire
duration of this government but they're
supposed to be the government that
stands up for defense of these islands
it's a disgrace and worst of all how
dare they deny democracy in scotland the
people of these islands are not confused
in scotland madam deputy speaker they
don't vote snp out of some sort of habit
or tradition they vote smp because they
recognize our values and their values
and they do not recognize the values of
the party opposite one iota and they're
smirking and laughing madame deputy
speaker will laugh up your sleeve i'll
tell you that because the people of
scotland are watching you they're
watching the disdain that you hold for
the decisions
too many times you've used the word you
you can you know in a general sense but
you were sort of implying things about
myself when you used the word you
went with disdain yes
dave dugan i wouldn't dream to do so
madam deputy speaker
they are laughing up their sleeve and
the people of scotland are recognizing
that and they don't like it one iota we
will have their say and we will divest
from this broken united kingdom once and
for all
you've asked for a more moderate
positive tone and i'll endeavor to do
that and i have full confidence in this
government for three reasons one because
no captain is more important than their
team and i think on this side of the
house we have a very very strong team
two because the government has delivered
for the country as a whole and a lot of
my colleagues have rehearsed the
arguments over brexit and covet and
ukraine and indeed net zero but three
because this government has delivered
for my constituency of south cambridge i
was elected here to represent the
interests of my constituents and it has
had a real impact on their lives this
government has delivered when it comes
to healthcare in south korea we've got
the new royal papworth hospital a
gleaming state-of-the-art hospital the
most important heart and lung hospital
in the uk just a couple of weeks ago we
opened the heart and lung institute the
biggest concentration of heart and lung
researchers in the whole of europe in
south cambridge
more is coming we've got the cancer
research hospital that's going to be
opened in 2025 and then the cambridge
children's hospital the first in the
east of england will be open shortly
after the first hospital of its type to
combine mental and physical well-being
of children the government is delivered
when it comes to transport for south
cambridgeshire we've got
cambridge south station opening in 2025
fully uh going through the process now
the a428 has been due
started dueling we've finished dueling
the a14 the gertin interchange that's
come the government has started looking
at that
the government's delivered for for the
environment in south cambridge one of
the big issues for us is chalk streams
protecting the short streams we have uh
the government set up a talk stream task
force we've passed new legislation on
sewage discharge which all the lived
mmps voted again shame on them they
voted to let dump sewage into short
streams we've brought in new hair
coursing laws really big issue in south
cambridge i had meetings with the home
secretary the secretary of state
environment about it we finally brought
in laws to stop this terrible crime
education spending is a really important
edition of south cambridge historically
it's been one of the lowest in the
country but actually we've now had a
21.3 increase in real terms in education
funding in cambridgeshire since 2014.
just in the last two years at 453 pounds
per pupil increase in education spending
and the schools are starting to feel the
difference we need more but it's made
it's already made a difference
when we had the kovid pandemic the
government delivered support for
businesses and individuals 17 000 people
were on furlough their jobs are saved by
the government over 50 million pounds in
funding for businesses and i know a lot
of my
small businesses in particular in
hospitality in particular pubs were
saved by the intervention of this
government and the support it gave it
research is a very big thing in south
cambridge i've got hundreds literally
hundreds of research institutes and
companies and the government is
increased funding on research and
development to 22 billion a year by 2025
and that's making a real difference for
south cambridge and finally police
we actually have record numbers of
police officers in cambridgeshire now
1671 as of march we've never had more
than we have at the moment so for all
these reasons the government is
delivering for south cambridge and i
would like to have full support full
confidence in this government
all right
thank you madam deputy speaker door
knocking in newcastle yesterday a young
mum of two told me she had never found
it so hard to manage the cost of living
crisis meant that she could barely
afford to get her two two kids to school
government was doing nothing to help and
she and her friends joked that they
would have to start selling their
kidneys
now mr madam deputy speaker that is the
kind of gallows humor
of a country in crisis
it doesn't belong in one of the richest
nations on earth
i have no confidence in a government
which does not support working families
in newcastle
i i think she's made i would like to say
my honorable friend is making excellent
speech and i would just like to add that
this is the this issue is found across
the country in every part of the country
including in the south of england she's
making an excellent point and i hope the
government listens to her
i'd like to thank my honorable friend
for uh for underlying that part order
and can i just say i think it's really
important that um people remember a lot
of people have put in to speak and it is
important that we get to them and
if colleagues want to take interventions
absolutely no problem i would strongly
encourage them to stick within the four
minutes if they wish to take
interventions chiang mara thank you
yes um madam deputy speaker i have no
confidence in a government which does
not support working families in
newcastle
and when people have no confidence in
the government it drains their
confidence in politics and democracy
generally
after all that has tested our country
the financial crisis austerity brexit
covert inflation it is more important
than ever that we have confidence in our
leadership
but i have no confidence in this
government
because the prime minister repeatedly
told parliament that there had been no
parties and then was fined for partying
i have no confidence in this government
because as our queen
contemplated the loss of her life
partner of 73 years
alone
downing street partied
i have no confidence in this government
because each and every minister whether
they resigned or not is tainted by the
support they gave to the disgraced but
still presiding prime minister i have no
confidence in this government because
the prime minister does not find formal
sexual misconduct complaints against a
servant government minister
memorable i have no confidence in this
government because the minister for
brexit opportunities and government
efficiency when asked to justify
slashing 91 000 civil servants
said technology would enable them to do
more with less the right honourable
member for the middle ages only
reluctantly agreed to a digital
apartment a digital parliament and is
happy to give the impression that the
printing press is a recent and debatable
innovation
i have no confidence in the government
because
when giving a valedictory assessment of
his meteoric rise and fall the
expensively eatening and oxford educated
prime minister said
and i quote them is the breaks i have no
confidence in the government because
they have decided to do without a
science minister even as they say
science is essential to our economic
recovery i have no confidence in this
government because as our nation faces a
lethal heat wave one so severe that the
railings between westminster and my
constituency have been severed and the
nhs has braced for a wave of heart
stroke victims the prime minister
preferred to play at top gun rather than
turning up for cobra meetings i have no
confidence in this government because
the candidates to replace the disgraced
prime minister are so mired in
mudsliding they barely mentioned health
education jobs or the environment and
they've now cancelled further debates
because they are so embarrassing i have
no confidence in this government because
they appear to be in an arms race to
slash taxes cut the state and postpone
or abandon our commitment to net zero
carbon emissions madam deputy speaker as
we swelter
in this country we should remember that
the whole of europe is less than
two-thirds the size of the sahara desert
and if we do not meet the climate
challenge the sahara is coming for us
and if they think net zero commitments
are expensive they should try costing
retrofitting every home school and
building in this country with air
conditioning and that will be but a
small part of what it will cost us
so i have no confidence in this
government because it has no ideas and
no convictions it is a zombie government
worse it is a vampire government
effectively dead but still continuing to
suck the lifeblood for my constituents
only a labour government can give us the
fresh start we deserve
and may i just say that my colleagues on
this side of the house look very much
alive to me and
looking back over the last two and a
half years i think we can say with
confidence that the government has done
a lot of things well
we left the eu when so many said that
that wasn't possible our covered
response has been one of the best in the
world the furlough scheme delivered at
extraordinary speed prevented the horror
of mass unemployment early decisions
taken on vaccine procurement saved
countless lives and enabled the uk to
leave lockdown sooner than almost any
other comparable nation
on ukraine this government and our prime
minister have led from the front not
only in terms of sanctions but in terms
of providing military and moral support
and in my constituency of peniston and
stocksbridge the government is
delivering on our manifesto promises to
level up
the towns fund will see 24 million
pounds invested in stocks bridge and
deep car government grants have rescued
cultural assets like the paramount
cinema a new fiber in the water project
in peniston offers the possibility of
rolling out broadband high-speed
broadband to rural homes the prime
minister's personal intervention on
behalf of the steel industry in
particular to keep the steel safeguards
has been a boost for local industry and
an important demonstration of this
government's commitment to areas that
were once the powerhouse of this country
and can be again
no administration is perfect and ours
has made its fair share of mistakes
but this government has done many things
nationally and locally to inspire
confidence
but of course i speak in the context of
huge uncertainty at the heart of
government the prime minister has
resigned i've lost track of who hasn't
resigned and we're in the middle of the
process of choosing a new leader
now the events of the last six months
will be chewed over relentlessly in the
coming years
but let us not forget that despite the
prime minister's mistakes and
misjudgments 14 million people voted for
our party under his leadership securing
the biggest conservative majority for
three decades
and unlike so many other politicians
my righteous friend the member for
uxbridge has the ability to inspire to
uplift and to connect with those who
feel like the british establishment does
not represent them their community or
their values now after 2016 the
reputation of parliament suffered as
ordinary people watched on as the
establishment as they saw it sought to
overturn the biggest popular mandate of
all time
my concern is that when a coalition of
the media the opposition and sadly some
within our party work relentlessly and
now ultimately successfully to
destabilize a prime minister with such
an extraordinary democratic mandate we
may once more be accused of trying to
overturn the democratic will of the
people
so as we on these benches are engaged in
the process of choosing our next leader
let us consider this
no one is without fault no one is
without a past
no one who has the skills experience and
charisma to lead our great nation will
never make a mistake
no one has never lied
we have been told that the prime
minister had to go because of his lack
of integrity and a tendency to change
his mind
the previous prime minister had to go
because she had too much integrity and
refused to change her mind
perhaps like goldilocks we will now find
are just right but our party is a broad
church and we have a broad range of
candidates vying to lead it whoever wins
we must unite the type behind his or her
leadership and stand firm against
attempts to throw us off course
perhaps madam deputy speak speaker the
question is not who is ready to lead but
are we ready to be led
so yes madam deputy speaker i do have
confidence in this government i have
confidence in the british people who put
this government in place and i wish the
new practical order hannah bardell
the speaker
oh would some power the gifty gears to
see ourselves as others see us they are
the words of the great scottish poet
robbie burns and they're as resonant now
as they were then because if we cannot
as politicians see ourselves as other
seers we have little hope of governing
responsibly or with credibility and i
suspect if the prime minister and some
with their delusions of grandeur on
those benches could see themselves as
people in my livingston constituency and
across all of our constituencies could
see them and they could see the damage
that their government has done to them
they would be and should be horrified
and that's the problem with this
government and with this prime minister
some have become so used to the
privileges and entitlements and
trappings of government that they have
become utterly insulated from reality
our citizens have the right not to have
confidence in this government this
political system and these political
institutions in westminster because
quite frankly as this government and
this prime minister has shown they are
utterly broken
now the prime minister we shouldn't be
surprised we have ended up with someone
who has come from one elitist
institution to another from eaton to
oxbridge to the house of commons and
actually we have 50 percent of the
conservatives a privately educated and i
was struck by a tweet recently from from
uh from
yeah okay jonathan gullis but remember
what i said about people who were trying
to catch my eye and chose to intervene
earlier down the list
i'm very grateful to you honorable lady
for giving away the honourable lady
makes this uh cast as dispersions
against people who attended private
school i found it quite disrespectful
man speaker that my mother and father
who chose to send me to that school
and decide to send use their hard-earned
money to give me the best start in life
that they unfortunately didn't receive
themselves should somehow be insulted in
this way
i think i think there's just a very
basic reality and i wanted to read the
tweet of the academic taj ali who
highlighted that just seven percent of
british people are privately educated 43
of the most influential news editors and
44 of news columnists are privately
educated a two-tiered education system
creates a two-tier society
speaker and that's the point i'm making
because we have a prime minister who is
completely devoid and divorced from
reality and the current leadership race
and its naval gazing narcissism has
given a window into that elitism and
privilege because among them we have one
of the most rich rich richest men in the
uk by who is on admission knows
literally no one who is working class
and only
did they quit government when they
realized that their own reputations were
going to be tainted so whether it's the
windrush scandal or the post office
horizon chrysler there is a litany of
chaos behind this government and i have
no confidence in this government because
it's failed to build proper social
housing failed to fund a health service
that was already on its knees before the
pandemic failed to protect the most
vulnerable in our society and has
instead cut the financial lifelines to
the poorest and most vulnerable and has
sought to balance the books on their
backs whilst vilifying them now the snp
government in scotland is sick to the
back teeth of cleaning up the mess of
the story government using our precious
resources with one financial hand tied
behind their back to clean up their mess
mitigating the bedroom tax lifting the
poorest and most marginalized out of
poverty without the full basket of
financial powers is hugely challenging
but we do it because we understand what
it means to govern in everyone's
interest and this tory government has
failed because it failed to quell the
river of dirty russian money flowing
through its financial system i sat in
the sanctions and anti-money laundering
bill with my honorable friend from
glasgow central and i saw this
government turn its back on the
opportunity to stem the corruption and
flow of dirty money so whilst we are
grateful for what they have done in
ukraine it is an absolute disgrace that
this prime minister this government and
previous prime ministers did so little i
have no faith in this government because
it presided over a right-wing brexit
that has torn our social and economic
fabric apart
and i understand
and we understand the notion of
credibility so madam deputy speaker the
sooner scotland can get independence the
sooner scotland can flourish and the
rest of the uk can i hope have its own
democratic enlightenment it can be free
from the chaos and the corruption that
this westminster system of government
holds and i have no confidence in this
government because i am sick and tired
of hearing members opposite on the
television talk about how when they
heard personal experiences of those who
lost loved ones during the pandemic
that because his prime minister their
prime minister parted his way through it
that somehow we don't have a right to
challenge that and the reality is and
the honourable member might shake his
head but i had to stand at the deathbed
of one of my team and dear friends
through a window in her hospice because
i was not allowed to cuddle her while
his prime minister parted his way
through and there he is still sitting in
power
oh order
james daley
thank you very much
thank you very much indeed madam deputy
speaker and i have to say that at least
there have been some serious
contributions madam deputy speaker
talked with her today and one of them
has been quite enlightening because i've
often wondered
what it is that people are seeing in the
snp government because it's not a
government that's trashed the economy
that has trashed the education system
that's trashed the health system it's
bankrupted it has one
drug problems in the western government
the absolute definition of incompetence
actually come here absolutely
no more nonsense about the rubbish we've
just heard this is about uh emotional
confidence and we hear from a party who
have a record of utter and dismal
failure that they attempt to criticize
us
which is truly laughable so can i turn
madame dick to speak it's great to
manchester
can't hear
james daley thank you very much uh
madame uh deputy speaker so let's turn
to the record we've now covered the s p
record let's let's see the record of the
labour party in greater manchester
which my constituents are faced for now
with that great political titan the
mayor of greater manchester what have we
had we have greater manchester police in
special measures of which he is police
and crime commissioner we have the iops
computer system which has cost about 800
million all under and burned completely
wasted we have mental health services in
special measured in greater manchester
under the control of andy burdem utter
complete disaster and the cherry on the
cake was when he attempted to impose
upon people in greater manchester the
world's biggest green uh like i can't
say the word green air charging zone
where andy burner's big idea was to
charge my constituents anywhere between
10 and 60 pounds to have the temerity to
go to work that's what they're faced
with the labour controlled council in
perry
their great record comes down to this i
could only go through the litany of
failure but in the very times today
madam deputy speaker
children's services in berry mental
health services in barrie are on its
knees due to our labour control council
and that
the the headline in the paper is it's
going to take 10 years for labor control
bury council to get children's services
back to even a good rating this is under
a labour council so the record of the
party's opposite in terms of how they
have interacted as governing bodies
throughout this country and with my
constituents is absolutely abysmal and
it is a shame for me i i wish the lady
from birmingham
yardley was in here because the thing
that she that the honorable lady missed
out when we're talking about rape and
serious sexual offending which is an
incredibly serious record which he never
touches on is the abysmal record of the
leader of your position as director of
public prosecutions something that
liberty quite rightly never talk about
absolutely and they throw allegations
out regarding this government's record
so what do we do
so what do we have in was this
government my government has spent 10
million pounds on building this new stem
uh high skill center in berry it has
saved gig lane and given my constituents
about their football club of 130 years
it's invested 80 million pounds into
transport infrastructure it's provided
20 million pounds for a leveling up bid
for bury town center and mysteriously
the honourable member for berry south
which isn't here
i know that he would want to go
gentlemen notified
the
other old joker that his name i will i
will draw that oh i will say that within
the metropolitan borough of berry we
have another leveling up fun bait in the
for the people of radcliffe a new school
coming from the people of radcliffe and
an scnd school providing support service
for some of the most vulnerable people
in my communities this is a government
to be proud of and a record to be proud
oh well
prime ministers
bluster and van turley's
stock and trade mockery ended today
and it was a little more than
a effectively a pointy finger rhetorical
raspberry
not just to us
but to everyone
who ever made the mistake
of holding to him
holding him to his word
and believing what he told them
he is a law-breaking prime minister who
cannot be permitted to remain in office
even as a caretaker
his dishonesty and abuse of power
have together only serve to erode trust
in politics and our institutions my
party you'll not be surprised to hear
does not have confidence in this prime
minister or his government
but that's to come back to that question
of eroding trust this is why i
introduced a private members bill which
will make it an offence for politicians
knowingly to lie be given every
opportunity to correct the record but to
be held to account in law
for using words our stock in trade
genuinely and honestly to the best of
our ability i have also written as you
would do
to the conservative leadership
candidates inviting them to support this
bill because they've made truth and
honesty core tenants of their campaigns
as they attempt to separate themselves
from the outgoing prime minister who
they all of course support it
the bill seeks to ensure that those who
deliberately lie are held to account but
also to send a signal that lying and
dishonesty are a blight to be eradicated
in a modern democracy
my party's lack of confidence goes
beyond this government besmirched as it
is in westminster scandal
but it's driven by wider deep-rooted
problems of the union
we distrust the union we lack confidence
in the union
the uk is foundering in deep stagnation
from years of tory austerity to a hard
tory brexit which is hobbling our
economy it's no wonder that poland is
set to become richer than britain in 12
years time on current growth rates
and of the tiny growth predicted it
won't be ordinary working families who
feel the benefit the tuc estimates that
the uk will see the worst wage squeeze
out of the g7 economies with real wages
real average wages falling by 1 750
pounds between 2022 and 2023
in wales we seek the macroeconomic tools
that continue to be denied the bare
necessities to fix westminster's chronic
tolerance of geographical inequalities
if we look at the place of whales
specifically within the uk we can see
things are so bad since 1998 relative
productivity in wales has hovered
between 80 and 85 percent of the uk
level once london's disproportionate
weight is accounted for the figure is
still only 90
wales
has been given the tools to juggle
poverty not to condemn poverty to
history
how can we have confidence in a
government and system that perpetuates
such gross inequalities the government
uk government talks of leveling up but
instead of presenting a comprehensive
plan for redistributing wealth they have
forced councils to fight over dwindling
pots of money today the institute fiscal
studies have shown how this government's
leveling up agenda doesn't work for
wales through its ideological insistence
to exclude welsh governments from
decision-making the ifs says this has
led to worse outcomes for wales
just to close now
despite this we saw the conservative
leader in wales recently called for no
further powers to be the world and the
consequential funding for hsr2 should
wait for it be controlled by the uk
rather than welsh government this is a
staggering insult to our democracy in
conclusion
we have no confidence in the current
government
and we have no confidence in any
westminster government yeah yeah
paul bristov
i'm deputy speaker
won't surprise honourable members that i
do have confidence in this government
and i want to talk first a little bit
about policy and some of the policies
this government have pursued now it
would be very easy madam deputy speaker
for me to talk about brexit about how
this um
how this government
managed to get brexit passed got through
that dreadful impasse that political
paralysis of the last parliament as
members opposite did everything they
could do